sr system
okay well we will then expl explain how
to build an
asr system for the arabic language with
uh tensorflow
presented by nurseen fershishi and
ability from monstadip
for those who don't know ances it's
uh it's founded in 2014 as datip is an
emea leader in decision making ei
products
for the enterprises with a
headquarters in london an office in
paris tunis lagos dubai
and capta nasa deep has built products
such as
its innova deep chain platform that
tackle the most complex challenges
across a range of industries so asda
deep
has also developed collaborative
collaborations
with global leaders in the artificial
intelligence intelligence ecosystem
such as such as google deepmind
nvidia and intel the comp the company is
part of
intel's ei builders program and was
named a preferred deep learning partner
by
nvidia we also have gdg cartage
who are present with us jdg cartage or
google developer group cartage is an
independent group active in north africa
and the
and the mina region we usually organize
events
uh meetings and training related to
google technologies in tunisia
like tensorflow machine learning android
flatter
or even cloud and ux design for startups
and we are open to any anyone interested
in our
activities our group allows you to
connect
virtually or in person with local and
international developers to bring
together
great opportunities so
thank you for the three companies here
with us
uh we will we're very well present a
full tts pipeline for transforming text
to speech for a given language
with email salemi and khalil uh homer
from studio
and finally we'll give an overview of
the latest ai language models trends
trends and improvements with kalim gear
from steady
so every attendee here if you have any
question you can refill
refeed to the q a section
in inzu where they will be answered
after the
litworks so we will start now with the
first talk
tunisian nlp challenges from building a
language model to downstream
tasks fine tuning these speakers will be
hatham hadid
he's a co-founder and cto at icampus he
received the doctorate in computer
science and
information systems from university uh
in alps france his current
research and terrorists include natural
nlp nlp machine learning
and deep learning uh we have also with
us
uh malik nasty uh
malek melek i'm sorry my leg is a final
engineering student at the national
engineering school of tunis
specializes in computer science she she
joined at thai campus in
in a year and works mainly on nlp
systems
her current interest involves most large
mostly large-scale deep learning and nlp
systems
so welcome to hatham and malik
thank you khalid for the introduction so
i
as harleen introduces we will talk uh
about tunisian nlp challenges from
building a language model to downstream
task fine tuning so i will start by
having
a general idea about nlp
mainly arabic nlp what was done before
and
some revolutions that started since 2013
with this file
and that allows us today to have
great products in the industry and and
the market
so if we will check the past in the next
slide
so mainly for decades we focus it on
msa the modern standard arabic so the
nlp arabic community
focused only on this for decades
they worked on low level processing
energy processing like stemming
limitization part of speech
creating dictionaries lexicons but no
one was talking about
dialects all the the effort was done
on the modern standard arab and
for me and for icompass this is
not really our focus because we believe
that
people they talk different languages
they talk different dialects the msa
is the language that we use every day in
informal way
so to write documents for administration
etc but it's not our way of
communication
so the tunisian for example and i will
talk a little bit at the end about the
tunisian
characteristics it's completely
different from the modern standard
arabic
that's why for industry we had
very very few arabic nlp applications
that
was in the market until few years ago
and this is
because uh the arabic language did not
attract
attention for big companies so if we
talk about big companies selling
electro products or cars or etc they
didn't focus on
on all the arabic language and when
talking about these companies they
they were telling me that anyway you
talk french or
english in your country and it's enough
for you to have
french products or english products no
need to go
and work on your on your dialects
another reason why we didn't have nlp
arabic nlp applications in industry is
that
all the applications had the very very
low performances
and this is for me because two reasons
the people working on
nlp at the beginning they were
linguistics
they were not really computational
linguistics as we have
today and for a linguistic it's just to
find rules grammar
etc but not really
programming a service or
a software to to solve problems
another reason was also that all these
products
were time consuming
and for endlessly to have a high
time-consuming product it's not
enough to put it in the market
so what happened after in the next slide
uh for me what happened is a revolution
that started in 2013.
the day i saw this paper uh from thomas
mikolov
about the war to veg for me it was the
beginning of a new era
about how we can do arabic nlp
without going deep into all these
details about stem inclematization part
of speech
so now we can do a lot of things and we
focus
on the performance rather than all the
pre-processing
steps that can take a lot of time and
still very complex for the arabic
language
from here we had report to veg then we
had sec
to veg etc
and we saw the performances of all the
products going higher and higher
and in the next slide i had thomas
as a keynote speaker when i organized
the
signaling 2016 in in turkey as a keynote
speaker and talking with him i told him
you made the revolution
and the nlp filed and he told me my
friend
were to make just a candle in the dark
soon we will have electricity
he's a very uh humble scientist but
a few years after he was right because
in the next slide we had the electricity
and this electricity
is the birth model when the birth mother
was released by
google in 2018 2019
it made a big difference in the state of
the art
in different nlp
applications so the idea here is to
create a big
language model and from this language
model
we can do any fine tuning
with it to apply it in in different
applications
uh kerem at the end we'll we'll focus
more
on this and we'll show why we need this
language models
and why it's important today to have
these language models
but still here we are at the electricity
era
for me what will come after and this is
we'll see it in the next slide
it's your future the future is yours and
i believe that
with twin birth and with your creativity
we will have the nuclear
power and this nuclear power will make a
big difference
in the everyday arabic country
people who will have new products in the
markets that are more focused
on arabic on dialects we are talking
about industry 4.0
that will come soon in our countries we
are talking about
smart cities smart cars and all these
products they need
to interact with people in their
own dialect that's why today
we release the twin board it's for you
for young generation
for me i i will i will stop at the
electricity level but i will leave you
the nuclear level for you to use
all the creativity that you have and i
believe you have a lot of energy a lot
of motivation a lot of creativity
to create new products that will make
our future and
your future so if i
um if you allow me to give you some tips
or recommendations
i see many cvs that students focus on
coursera courses udacity etc etc this is
good
a good beginning a good step maybe
because today
at the universities we don't have a
curriculum
or courses
up today to talk about nlp to talk about
artificial intelligence it's a good uh
starting point with this
uh coursera or audacity courses but
still not
enough to be expert in in the nlp
file my recommendation is to go for more
advanced
courses i recommend the chris manning
course from stanford
he made all his courses are online
they are very very good they go from
lower
complexity to high complexity with labs
with practice
etc he was my mentor for many
years and he is one of the
biggest name today in into nlp
and last but not least what i recommend
is to practice practice practice this is
how we can progress because practice is
is the main master uh better to practice
than to spend hours on videos on youtube
etc
with practice you can learn more and
faster
so they saying this if you don't have
any
questions i will allow
i will invite malek to talk us
to talk to us more in detail about how
we create a june birth
and what is a language model
hadith there is no question that until
now we can move to the next section
yeah of course
so uh thanks
hi everyone uh this is malik from
icompass
uh i participated in building uh
chambered aka
the first donation pre-trained language
model um
and uh which is a collaboration between
instadeep and icon pass
and as hadam said bert actually
revolutionized the nlp field in these
last couple years
and we actually started seeing people
all over the world building
language specific birth-based models and
even though
a multilingual birth does exist which
was trained
on many different languages um many
dialects and languages are still
under presented today just like the uh
tunisian dialect
so we said to ourselves why not eight
emission birds
and in order to dive deeper into reasons
why we
are needed uh to build a tunisian bird
we will actually have to understand
how uh birth works and why does it even
exist
so as harton said um bert is actually
a way to build uh you can build actually
language models
that are basically a representation of a
natural language of your choice
and you can afterwards fine tune it on a
specific uh downstream task
so um here the tricky part is that
the most data-hungry and the most uh
computationally demanding parts is
actually
the pre-training part of the part where
we actually build the language model
and the bright side here is that this
part
is an unsupervised training and it does
not require any labeled data and you
know how
expensive annotating data and labeling
it can be
so this is a huge advantage for us
so we can actually build this language
model
and then each person that has a
label data set that is much smaller can
actually perform downstream tests and
still achieve state-of-the-art results
on them
so um and since the television dialect
data is scarce especially the annotated
data
stem words here can be the solution for
many of us especially
students and people who do not have
access to large label data sets
so uh we actually provide a
the major building block of this model
which is the language model
and then you guys can perform downstream
tasks with your
your own uh label data sets
so um why tensorflow
and this is a denser cloud meter so we
will talk about
our tensorflow implementation of the
chambered model
and as you may know uh the first verse
ever
was released by google and made with
tensorflow the tensorflow one
and during this collaboration we
actually wanted to accelerate the
process we wanted to
um perform the training in a distributed
fashion
and since the original codebase was
actually written in a tester for one
it's kind of outdated
we actually had to seek code that is
written in
tensorflow 2 in order to take advantage
of tensorflow 2's merit strategy that
makes us able to perform distributed
training
so luckily tensorflow has a
github repository that is called model
garden
and it has implementations of many
popular state-of-the-art models
including birds and other huge models
and
it helped us to migrate the original
code from to native tensorflow 2 and
take advantage of the mirror strategy
and now we can actually distribute
so as for the how we actually
uh built the model and guys i cannot
stress this enough
you can do this yourselves uh and uh all
the script of the code
you will actually have to make minor
changes but the major
building blocks are already there for
you so um
if you wish to build any language model
in any dialect or language that you wish
you can actually do this
so how does did the process um
how did we how was the process for us so
we had to collect and scrape data
typical we had to clean it process it
and
finally fire up the training so
um for the data collecting part
we actually um went and sought data from
many online sources um many social media
facebook twitter instagram youtube you
name it
and um we actually wanted to make sure
that
the data is well representative of what
tunisian people are saying online
so we had to cover as many top topics as
possible as many
regional dialects as possible and we
included for example
music politics tv shows news
casual conversations between random
people etc so
uh the tunisian um text that we
we chose that the tunisian text that we
train on
is written in arabic letters only and we
wanted our data set to be as large as
possible because
too much is never enough with these kind
of models and especially
uh birth based models and um
we ended up with having actually 500k
lines of tunisian text written in
arabic letters so as for the data
cleaning
we had to do the typical things remove
emojis punctuation symbols
then gf characters etc and we had to
also do a
processing to keep only sentences that
are in arabic
in tunisian arabic because we also had
um synthesis in french english arabic
which is romanized
romanized arabic layers with also
numbers etc so we
had to do this type of pre-processing
but
and the thing that is important here is
that we do not do any limitation or any
typical nlp preprocessing
simply because the model actually has to
receive
the sentence that it is as it is
naturally said and written by
a normal human being so that it actually
can understand the context
because birth is the first deeply
bi-directional and contextualized model
so it has to get the entire sentence in
order to
understand how the language or the
dialect works in a natural way
so um now we can actually move on to
uh creating the data in a format that
bert
actually needs and first of all we have
to build a vocabulary
uh and here we use the workpiece
tokenizer
which is going to prevent take take our
the entire data set it is going to
prevent
the sub words which occur in the middle
words with number sign number sign
and the sub words occurring at the
beginning of words are going to be
unchanged
and if the sub subword occurs both in
the beginning and the middle of words
uh both versions are going to be added
to the vocabulary
so like this we build a vocabulary that
has uh
sub words of our data set that is
supposedly representative of intonation
dialect
right so afterwards we add special
tokens or special control symbols that
are required to chain birth
such as the padding token the unknown
token the beginning of sentence the end
of sentence token the masking token etc
because words works um through amazing
words and trying to guess them
so that it builds knowledge on the
certain uh dialect or language that
we're working on
and we also had add some unused or
placeholder tokens in order to
um use them in the future so for example
if you want to take the language model
and uh train it even further and
if there are tokens that do not exist
and the recovery they're going to be
added in these
placeholder tokens so um
here for example uh we have our
tokenizer we have our vocabulary uh file
and we try to tokenize this uh sentence
that is written
in arabic so here you can see that
uh the letters here are latin and it
does not
understand them because um our
vocabulary actually contains
as we mentioned before the tunisian that
is written in arabic characters
so here we can see that the tokens are
unknown unknown unknown
so um in this uh
in this sentence for example which is
written in arabic
we can see that the tokenizer does the
tokenization and adds the number sign
to um to the sub words uh and here too
so the sentence is from youtube i guess
uh
so this sentence has been tokenized as
you can see according to
our initial data set and uh therefore
our vocabulary file so um
as for generating pre-training data and
just to remark here guys maybe you can
find
a frameworks uh that can actually do all
this to you
for you but um in the original uh
birth this is how it happens so this is
what happens under the hood
so the for the data formatting part uh
we generate pre-training data
that is compatible with the word format
so what happens
first we have the tokenization uh the
data set is broken down into sentence
into tokens so each sentence is broken
into tokens
and we add the needed tokens at the
beginning
at the end of sentences and we pad the
sentences that are
which land is less than the maximum
sequence map that we set
we actually have to pad them and uh
we convert each token into their
corresponding id
and the model and you have the scripts
to do all this inverts repository
so don't worry about that and as for the
architecture we actually
had to keep the birth base architecture
unchanged
and it is basically a stack of
bi-directional transformer encoders
we keep the standard architecture we did
not change it
and the total parameters here are going
to be 110 million
um as for the hyper parameters we were
actually inspired by previous works
because
uh the pre-training takes days and it's
really expensive and
really time consuming to just tune the
hyper parameters for the pre-training
parts
so we were inspired by previous work and
um
we chose the high parameters to be this
way
so um as for the training and now with
our
training we did it on uh four nvidia
tesla volta 100 gpus
using tensorflow's merit strategy to
distribute the training
so uh this was done on onenote on
a google cloud platform and
uh you may ask yourselves what
is the mirror's strategy and how does it
work
so here actually we use something that
we
call in the state of the art uh data
parallel
uh synchronous sgd or synchronous
stochastic gradient descent so how this
happens is that
the parallelization here is happening on
the data not on the model
so um all of the variables and monograph
are going to be replicated
on the gpus and the data is going to be
evenly distributed on the gpus so for
each
step if we have a batch of data
for the entire model this batch is going
to be
split into sub-batches and each
sub-batch is going to be
processed by a gpu and this gpu will
calculate the gradient
so it will do the forward the backward
pass and
it will then they will send their
gradients and they will be synchronized
all over the gpus
and they will be reduced or
the mean is going to be calculated and
afterwards
the weights are going to be updated all
over the gpus once again
and each gpu is going to be making the
calculation on each
but new batch of data and each time
this is going going to happen going
forward and backwards with the
hyper with the uh sorry with the weights
and this is how the weights are going to
be uh updated and synchronized at the
same time between
uh different gpus so um this is quite
interesting especially if you have large
models
and uh especially if you want to reduce
the training time so here
we uh actually just attaining time by
processing bigger batches at a time
holistically speaking so if we
see it from a a higher level we can see
that the patch size is quite big
but it's actually just smaller batches
to each gpu so um
yeah this uh this is actually a uh
a representation of how it actually
happens uh the
uh ways are going to be uh to be
calculated
and sent back to populate the meme the
entire ways of the entire network are
going to be updated again and sent back
to
views et cetera so um
you can find chambers on github on
instagram and i can pass these
repositories
and um you will also find uh
an implementation in python using
uh the nemo toolkit so you can use
whatever you want you can use the
tensorflow implementation the button
implementation you're actually free
um so yeah if you have any questions
about this part
uh i'll be glad to hear them and answer
them and
yeah thanks for listening thank you
malik so yeah we have a lot of questions
um okay can we fine tune
bear to create american version
i'm sorry can you fine-tune a
convert to create american version
um i believe that tombert was was
created for the tunisian dialect
even though there is similarities
between the tunisian dialect and the
moroccan one but uh
creating a a language model for the
moroccan
is more relevant in this case than
fine-tuning
uh twin birth for the moroccan language
uh
going from a dialect to another dialects
words they have a different
um sense or meaning that means a word in
tunisia that
can have a specific meaning when the
same word in moroccan can have a
different
meaning that's why i suggest to create a
new language model for the american
language
okay thank you uh
so khadija said thank you for your
presentation you recommended
practicing but how exactly could you uh
how exactly
could you please give us uh some
specific tips
i can talk of my case when i started
working on nlp i
check a problem solved in english or or
french and
i try to to do the same for arabic and
create my own
solution for the arabic language that
means
take any any any kind of problem named
entities recognition
or information retrieval and apply the
same
that was done for english to the to your
dialect this is how
how i used to to practice no need to be
a computer engineer or a
specialist in llp to uh or have a degree
in nlp to do this
anyone can today learn by by itself
thank you
okay next question how did you decide
the amount of data needed for the
pre-turn
pre-training
um this is as i said we actually
wanted to our data set to be as large as
possible
and this is actually the amount that we
could
uh scrape and scrape at the time and
maybe you guys can contribute with even
more data because
you actually have the option to uh train
the model even further on
further text and that you guys have and
maybe you can even enhance the model so
uh yeah that
that's all we could do outside so
we we have to know that the tunisian
dialect is very has
some specificities one of them is the
switching language so when we talk
tunisian or we write
we switch from latin to arabic
characters
we use some french words or english
words in the same sentence
so this this amount of data it wasn't
the original amount of data we collected
much more
and then when it comes to the cleaning
and filtering a lot of data was
a mix between arabic and and latin tuned
birth in june but we used only the
arabic
alphabet so words written in arabic
alphabets
just after i will talk about the the
latin
tunisian and i saw a question about this
and
i will be happy to talk a little bit
about this
this program a little bit later
yeah sure uh you can do it uh hotend
so if there is no more questions we can
move to the next uh
section uh we have another question is
convert available and accessible to us
as students to use it in our projects is
it
open source yeah it's open source it's
free to use
you have the links and we will put the
links also at the end of this
presentation
everything is is public and free for the
students for
also people working on research we
this was made for them
between asladeep and icompass we decided
to put it
free since the beginning to to allow our
students
and allow our researchers to uh to carry
on their
their practice and also their research
phd or master
thank you so a lot of tunisian dialect
data on the internet is available in
latin letters
how do you deal with this kind of debt
okay i will talk if you follow me i will
talk about this in the last part of the
of the speech i will focus in in this in
this main problem
okay uh
so sarah said there is a previous
attempt to make an english to
tunisian dictionary known as dejan
ninja.com
i don't know if you don't if you know
this do you think the data used for this
dictionary can be used to build or
update a model
she said also deja ninja has more than
17 000 entries
17 000 is not enough
previous works as i mentioned they they
focus it on
building dictionaries lexicons
all this knowledge base about the words
that we use
the relation between these words or
linguistic
like synonymy etc etc but i believe
and this is what what was uh proved by
linguistics that
dialects are a very very uh
[Music]
how to say the words in a dialect they
change meaning
a dialect is a very dynamic
language that is every day a new
language
you know this tunisian dialect but also
all
the other dialects from algeria or
morocco every day we have a new world
every day we have
a new expression every day the same word
can change meaning
in few days and that's why building
a static dictionary or static lexicon
for me it's not very accurate i i would
prefer a language model that we can
update
uh once in a in a while with new entries
then building manually a dictionary and
after we cannot update
thank you uh next question by scander
how do you handle the fact that several
styles of speech in tunisia in arabic
are not represented online the way old
people talk
or uh or the way a lot of people talk in
special contexts
like in certain public marketplaces
especially religious or social events uh
basically when you use online sources
a certain demographic of tunisian
speakers are
vastly over represented while others are
poorly represented
or unpresented at all together
okay
that's why when we we collect data we
try to make it as large
as possible and include the maximum
topics the maximum of
people expressing themselves in social
media or
in internet and after this is the
fashion or this is the
the the the good part of artificial
intelligence that we can handle
and we can uh process a lot a lot of
data in the same time
after if someone would like to focus in
uh demography
or um speaking ways in different regions
it's possible with uh with june birth
and also uh if i can add something
actually uh
in our training data set we also
included
uh data that is uh about tunisian
stories uh that are written in the
advances
so there is actually some data that is
representative
to uh to that is not real present online
but
is present in our data set certainly it
does underrepresented by
but we actually we're actually working
towards enlarging
uh the dataset and you guys can help too
since this is an open source
project thank you
uh so sarah asked if
would it be easier to use an arabic
programming language to avoid the clash
between latin letters
and arabic entries
i don't know if there is some arabic
programming languages
i didn't get the question though yeah me
too uh
i think she she's asking if
we change we use an arabic programming
language i don't know if there is an
arabic programming language
okay sarah if you can
really we ask the question
so
um
the question of scandal was already
answered
so uh i thought you used you have used
by torch with nvidia nemo
also i don't know is that true
yes okay yeah you can find the
both models on the repositories on
github
so amir asks if does the
pre-training enable enable the data for
to invert contain
msa in addition to tunisian dialects
also is it possible to use birth
embeddings to measure the
similarity between the dielectric world
and its
corresponding msa
it's a very philosophical what's the
difference between tunisian dialect and
msa there is an intersection between
them
of course some words are as the same
origin or we
use some msa in our tunisian
tunisian dialect maybe in the next
we can show how to um identify how to
use scrimber to fine-tune
a downstream task to identify between
two different dialects
we can use it also to identify tunisian
dialect
and msa so if you you allow us to move
to the next section we can
we can have some practice and show this
melee piece if you move to the next one
yes
which is a demo about how to use
to invert in one specific downstream
task
okay so uh in this example we will
actually
see how to fine-tune a chambered on a
downstream test which is dialect
identification
and this task will actually identify uh
tunisian and algerian dialects which are
which is a challenging test because
these dialects are
actually similar in some ways so
this demo was made by adir my colleague
so thank you again let's watch together
we are going to show you how to
fine-tune chambers on the dialect
identification task
using google collab
[Music]
first we clone google bird directory
we install then the appropriate
libraries
we import vtad dataset dataset is
divided into train
dev and test let's have a look at the
data distribution
the data contains comments in tunisian
dialect
annotated as zero and in algerian
dialect
annotated as one here
we show you the number of comments in
each set
the data is balanced we have the same
number
of comments in each dialect
we move now to the fine tuning step we
need the checkpoints
the vocab and the configuration files of
junebert language model
as we mentioned earlier they are
available in icompass
or insta chip githubs
we run the runclassifier.pi file
with a batch size of 16 a max sequence
length of 128
and for four epochs
during the fine tuning checkpoints will
be stored in the output directory
once the fine tuning is complete we move
to the prediction step
so we set to predict as true
testresults.tsv contains the prediction
probabilities of each class
finally we want to measure the
performance of our model
we get an accuracy and weighted average
f1 score of 91
that's amazing
that's amazing indeed so um
if you have any questions about this
specific
task or about the fine-tuning just ask
away
do we have any questions related to this
section
yeah uh so they're asking
uh
uh how does chambers compare to other
models for regional dialect in the
many region but actually this is the
first one
dedicated to a specific dialect what we
have in state of the art are different
language models but they are a mix
of a lot of dialects so we can find gulf
uh egypt levantine in the same language
model
what we did with birth is that we focus
it only on the tunisian dialect
and that's why the pre-processing and
filtering step was very important to us
to keep
only tunisian text
so you have a lot of different language
models in the state of the art going for
marburg i will talk about this a little
bit later
arbit et cetera but they are really a
mix
and what is interesting is that the
amount of data
in this and these language models when
it comes to
tunisian algerian or moroccan are very
very few
and i think they are not really
appropriate to use them
for um local dialects in north africa
okay uh how how will you evaluate to
invert on
fine-tuned text summarization task
knowing that bart architect architecture
outperformed birth in this task
i don't know if you could we didn't do
this
actually but the one who asked the
question can
practice all this
okay uh how much the training time for
to invert
and what hardware or cloud you have used
so for the uh
nemo or pytorch uh model into five days
uh we had to start the training for the
uh
chambered with the tensorflow
implementation at two days and a half
uh according to the uh loss method
so as for the hardware as i mentioned
before we trained on
one google cloud platform node that has
four gpus
uh four tesla volta 100gb
okay thank you so uh someone noticed it
while
he fine-tuned it to invert that the
first sentence is skipped when doing
predictions
is that a normal behavior or did did he
do something wrong
sorry first sentence yes
he knows he noticed when he find
trunatum birth
that the first sentence is keep it when
doing the prediction
i don't know what do you mean if the
first sentence is
the first sentence is skipped i don't
know
uh anonymous can you explain more
uh if you have any issue you can
actually raise an issue on github
there is no problem
okay uh
so are you planning to implement further
functions fortune belt
such as offensive language detection
why not but anyone can do it now
since certain birth is is available and
is public anyone can use it for uh for
any fine
tuning task that you can can imagine
that's why i said
i let your creativity to to the next
step
we created onboard for you but now it's
up to you to use it uh
and to play with it okay
so to invert dock will be improved on
the future because uh for now i find
i don't find it that user friendly uh
i don't know what is in birthduck
documentation i guess the readme file on
i don't know he said that it's not user
friendly
okay
you can create an issue on github and we
will be happy to
answer your question or modify our dock
to make it more easier for um
for everyone okay
so that's it i think
yeah okay thank you
so the in the last part of our talk
i will focus a little bit about the the
tunisia
as you know everyone is talking about
the arabic as the latin version
of the arabic language that's what
people use in the middle east or
north africa to write on social media or
sms or etc
but at i compost we find that there is a
big difference between arabic which is
as the origin was an egyptian
version of the latin which is called
arabic
english arabic and gliese that's why
it's called
arabisi and the tricompass when we did
our study we
we find out that our tunisian we call it
tunisian
in icompass is completely different from
the arabic used in the middle east
when we we use three five seven nine
it's different from what
middle east countries use in social
media so recently in 2020 we had a paper
in
uh icler and we defined the tunisia as
the romanized alphabet used to
transcribe
a formal arabic or informal tunisia for
communication by the tunisian social
media community
and we have a lot of examples to show
that they are completely different from
what
middle east people use so in the next
step
i i i jump on the first question
can you show us the next uh slide malek
please
yeah indeed what tunisian use on
internet
it's mainly latin character and we had
some studies here
about tunisian facebook comments and
almost 81 percent is latin character
and if we talk more general uh in
tunisian social media
we are also at a high level of
latin character and a small part also 30
but i guess now it's it's more this was
2019
i guess statistics in 2020 will show
more
switch code switching that means in the
same sentence people they can use
um different kind of characters arabic
and
and latin in the same language that's
why
in i-compass we paid attention at this
um
specific way of writing of tunisians in
on the social media and that's why we
created the tunisia
so in the next slide we proposed
in 2020 a data set annotated data
dataset
for sentiment analysis tunisian rbz data
set so let's
latin way of writing at the beginning we
created the small
data set about 10 10k commands annotated
manually
as positive and negative and
still this one is balanced and
public but still a small data set to be
used in real
applications or to make a real progress
in this
in this fight so that's why in the next
slide we created the second version of
this
it's the tunisia version 2. it's 100k
data set it's the largest data set
dedicated for the tunisian
arabisi it's almost balanced
so we can use it for for different
experiments
we included also some neutral commands
here
to make it as multi-label data set
and we used this for different
experiments
using the marburg that i talked before
in the next slide
giving quite good performances
to uh to do this exercise with latin
character
tunisian text so here we are almost at
eighty percent
um of uh accuracy and f1
micro for both classification or
multilingual
multi-label classification or binary
classification
and this that i said in the next slide
we use it
um we use it to create a competition
with
cindy at beginning of
of this year it was a very very popular
competition uh it's about social media
sentiment analysis fortunes in
arabic there were 740 data scientists
from all over the world different
different countries we are
we were really surprised to see students
from
ivary coast from chile from indonesia
working on the tunisia sentiment
analysis data set
at the beginning we were happy that the
top three
were tunisian and the second one is a
mix between a japanese team and tunisian
team
we were happy yes because for a long
long time there was a student
from israel who was top one ranked
and we were really surprised to not see
our tunisian
students achieving high performance and
this
we made this last year and we are
thinking now about creating more
competitions for the students
opening our data sets or part of our
datasets publicly
to be used by the tunisian or
the arabic community as a competition
it's another way of practicing which is
very very interesting
and i i am i ask all the students or
researchers to participate in this
competitions
this data set is also available online
it's free so in the next slide we have
all the references we have the twin
board references
that you can look at you can use we have
the
also the tunisia data set which is
publicly
available and finally keep
feel free to ask us any any and contact
us
with any question there is no stupid
questions on this file
any question can be interesting if you
have any idea about competition about
creating
a new data set feel free to contact us
and
we are open to any collaboration thank
you
thank you uh adam so a question what are
the use
use cases of this
of the tunisia yeah same as in arabic
nlp and any kind of use case that you
can think from
name it entity to sentimental analysis
hp detection
fake news there is a lot it's very very
large
we explored only a very small part but
still a lot to explore
okay the tunisian dialect is quite
limited
in terms of vocabulary items and this
results in words having multiple
meanings sometimes
something and it's opposite so how
how does timber deal with the
policymaking in the
tunisian dialect i really don't agree
with
the tunisian has a very small vocabulary
uh from memory um the dataset that we
used for birth it's about 400k
different words right my leg
500k uh lines of text actually and much
more
uh words uh do do you have um
the number of words different words
unique words
uh i think they're about eight million
or something like that
it's huge for for two reasons the
tunisian vocabulary is very very rich
and every day we have new words coming
the way of writing since it's on social
media and
for the tunisian dialect there is no uh
rules about grammar or the way we we
write things
that make it very very sparse and we
have a different
different uh words
polygamy we can we can handle it with
any uh machine learning or a deep
learning program to find out
what are the connections between words
and we
do we can do classification about
anonymity policy etc etc
but it's still a very rich vocabulary
and it's very interesting to work on it
and the same for morocco and algerian i
guess it's it's the same
team observation yeah
can something like mt5 or maybe
multimodal multitask embeddings like
m-u-m be used to handle uh tunisia
and tunisian written in arabic
an arabic alphabet simultaneously
i didn't get the question surely malek
if you have an idea please
feel free to answer
i think we can actually try with the mp5
type of language models and
uh i think that
every actually innovative thing in the
nlp
world on any language can actually be
tried on the tunisian dialect and we can
actually see what it gives
so as you can see we're actually
experimenting and seeing
what we get
oh perfect so uh
last last question a question
uh is there a way is there a way to fine
tune by
importing the model directly in
tensorflow
pytorch i would like to fine-tune
convert by adding some layer and
freezing some
not via the cmd commands way
it's a nice technical question here uh
yeah i believe so because it's actually
a checkpoint so
it's a checkpoint file that you'll
actually take and do whatever you want
with it
you can actually train it further you
can add layers to it you can
uh fine tune it on your task
the basic i mean the most important
thing here that we release
it's actually the checkpoint so you can
do whatever you want with it
yeah the same way as we did the dialect
identification
you can just import the the checkpoint
and then
use it for any application as as your
image
okay thank you to hatam and malik for
this
very interesting talk and very
informative
q a thank you very much to icampus
we go to our next talk with
uh with nourishment and
crochet for building asr systems for the
arabic language with tensorflow
for those who don't know nourishing
she is an aid search engineer at
unsteady tunisia
she has deep skills in natural language
processing
she has worked on challenging research
projects use
projects focusing on the latest advanced
nlp models
she has also delivered project product
projects
responding to real world business cases
for abeer corchette is an aie research
engineer at instead deep also
she holds a strong background in natural
language
understanding and speech recognition
tasks
she has developed deep learning models
to solve real world problems related to
understanding and recognition of human
languages
with emphasize on low in low resource
languages
so welcome to our beer and nursing
hello everyone um so i'll start by
um sharing my screen are you
able to scream
[Music]
yes we can see the screen hello everyone
okay so um thank you everyone for
attending this meeting
i'm very happy today to be part of this
tensorflow meetup in tunis
and in this presentation we will
introduce or help you learn how to build
your automatic speech recognition
model for asl for for arabic language
using tensorflow
so i'm nursing for research engineering
and i have with me hello uh hello
everyone
i am abby koscied ai research engineer
at institute mainly working on
nlp tasks i'm so happy to have you with
us and i hope that you will enjoy this
session
okay so this is the outline of this
presentation we'll start by a general
introduction to which
uh in which we will uh talk what is arl
asr in general
we'll go through some of the application
in the challenges we'll introduce
a basic standard but very efficient uh
pipeline and then some of the data sets
especially the arabic
and the north african dialects that we
can use
we'll introduce how you can build a deep
neural
network acoustic model and how you can
build on top of it a language model in
order to
make your model more efficient and we'll
end up with a jupiter notebook demo
using tensorflow i will have a summary
in
the conclusion and we will leave the
last 15 minutes for a q
a session
what is asr asa is just the abbreviation
of three different words automatic
speech and recognition and it is the
intersection between two different
fields
the first field is the computer science
which is the science of understanding
computer computers and computational
systems and the second field is the
linguistics which is the science of
understanding the human language
so um the global or general um
the general output of an asr system
should be that
we would have a speech and then we would
transform it into
ethics so for example here we would have
as
an input algebra
with and we would expect our model to
predict this
written text
so the question here is is asr still
part of the
research or we can use it actually in
our
daily uses and the uh answer to this
question
is definitely yes there are a lot of
industries that are using the asr first
of all the telecom industries
we are creating some kind of
conversational chatbots they are
there to enhance the customer support by
responding to their to your questions
resolving your technical issues and even
providing you personalized advice
for a preferred uh service integration
industry
and then the second one is the marketing
so for the marketing we are creating
voice search engines such that you can
record a description of a product
you are looking for and then you will
have a great accurate product
search responding to your use case
and today we hear a lot about internet
of things we hear words like
smart tv smartphones smart cars and
smart houses
and the common um thing between all of
those words is that
you give them a kind of instruction in a
vocal way
and then you get back
this is very interesting interesting as
you can do a lot of
uh things in a parallel way without even
using your hands
and a last uh field is the healthcare so
nowadays we use digital assistant uh to
help you in medical guidance
you can call your digital assistant and
tell him how
you feel you can feel a little bit of
fatigue you can have a high temperature
and the digital assistant will ask you
to for example get a little bit of rest
uh drink a lot of vitamin c's and maybe
take a test of coronavirus
and also the digital assistant are used
in internally with the medical stuff by
having access to um to information
especially administrative information in
a quick and in easy way
here after is a very interesting
application that
actually uses the arabic languages is
called
google so google manages your tasks plan
your days and get your answers all you
have to do is to say
okay google and the model or the um
google will answer you in arabic telling
you um
for example marhaban ke khayyam ki uni
so um i'll leave and now
um the floor for my colleague abir
thanks narshan now we are going to talk
about the challenges so the area of asr
is being discussed from past few decades
and it's still another research area
and it's still not easy to reach a
flexible solution
that satisfies the user and this is
mainly due to
some challenges to overcome let's start
let's have let's talk about few of them
we will talk about first of all about
the challenges from a linguistic
perspective
actually there are many sorts of
variations like the speaker if you have
for example a model which is tuned for
one speaker you
will the model will find it really hard
to
generalize on other speakers as we may
might already know each speaker has its
own characteristics
the environment may also influence the
quality of
the data having a noisy environment
or speaking in close environment may
cause
some may cause some echo or
reverberation which
deteriorate the quality of the audio and
makes it hard for the asr model to
recognize very well detect so it's
really important to
find ways to pre-process your data and
clean it
correctly other challenges are related
to the accent if you want
to have an asr model that could
recognize a language
uh you need to make sure that for each
language we have different speakers and
each speaker has its own
accent so we need a robust model that
would handle and understand the
different accents
this fluency and scattering also could
cause some problems
for the model and makes it so hard to
recognize words code switching is also
a challenge for the asr
systems as you can see here at the
bottom
at the bottom right an example which
shows
a text which contains arabic letters and
we have a july which is an english word
so for an asr system who is mainly
trained in a certain language for
example
for the arabic language you will find
that he will not recognize the
latin characters but he will as you can
see here
he tries to uh predict it the way he
understand it for this particular
challenge
we need to find some ways to pre-process
our transcripts if they contain some
latin characters
we need to transform latin characters
into arabic characters
and we write them the way we hear them
and there are also other techniques that
we could use which are uh
end-to-end models which perform language
detection they
that they could detect detect language
and based
on the language detect which was
detected he can perform the recognition
uh and there are other para linguistics
a problem related
basically to the emotional state of the
speaker
the actually the maybe uh as an example
the intensity of the
signal may differ from uh
the basic basing on the emotional state
of the speaker whether it is
uh he is happy or angry and so on
so let's now move to the second uh part
which where we will talk about the
characteristics of the arabic language
uh actually there is a difference
between the spoken and the written
language
posed mainly by the absence of
geocritics
let's see the example which is on above
the top bottom
of the button sorry left where you can
see this verse
if i would ask someone to read it
i'm pretty sure that the majority of us
will
end up reading it and not in the correct
way
because of the absence of the geocritics
okay so and when we add the jagrat
the jack retex we can read them
correctly
without jeopardics we see them all the
same uh
the same word but when we add the
geocritics we can
hear the difference between the
different words
you can see here there is a difference
when we add the decoratives
and when coming to asr systems this is
really important
and the system really needs this
information to
improve its performance but
unfortunately
in real public data sets
for the arabic the the majority of the
data sets are not
jeopardized you need you might need
to find tools that will help you to
jeopardize your data
in order to improve the performance of
your model
so um yeah let's move now to
talk about the challenges from a machine
learning perspective
as we already know the when we talk
about
deep learning especially we have two
main problems which are data and compute
power
so especially when we talk about
the asr for arabic and low resource
languages
there are now a lot of lots of resources
which are available and that
that we could use to get good
performance
uh yeah i think that's it uh regarding
the challenges let's now
uh introduce some keywords uh related to
the asr so i will pass over the speech
to my colleague norshan
to carry on this part thank you adir
so in the next slides we will go through
what a standard
easy asr pipeline would uh look like and
um here we go so when i start speaking
all starts with those two words that i
will be seeing for example i just take
the same example
and when i'm saying those two words i'm
generating some kind of vibration in the
uh air which is translated into an
acoustic
energy this acoustic energy can be
captured but by any acoustic device such
as a microphone
and this microphone has the ability to
transform this acoustic energy into an
electrical energy
the electrical energy can be measured
easily and then
plotted into a function of the amplitude
in function of the time
and this is exactly exactly sorry what
we call another
signal or a wave file or a waveform
so here if we have a look at the plot we
can uh
easily distinguish between two blobs
which actually correspond to the two uh
spoken words algebraia and the tunisia
so the higher my voice will be or the
higher pitch i will be using
the more energy i will be generating and
then the
higher values of amplitudes will be
print
in the the plot
and next would be to extract all
or most of the information from those
audio signals so we use here
what we call a spectrogram and it is a
way of transforming
a function of amplitude in terms of time
to a function of frequency in terms of
time
and we use him uh here an algorithm
called fft
or fast fourier transformation there
there's a lot of
math behind this we will not get into
details in this uh presentation but i
highly recommend you
to go and read more about it but the
main idea behind this is
um a simple or a simple um feature
or a simple apart from the uh wav file
is actually composed of
many frequencies some of the frequencies
are even not
human hurt and the sum of those
frequencies are what we call frequency
component when all
summit together we get what we call a
spectrogram
so spectrogram is actually the input of
my deep neural network
acoustic model and it has a goal to map
the relationship between the audio
signals to the phonemes
here the phonemes are the characters
that i'm pronouncing
it could be ha ha or even a composition
of two
uh heart fat etc and
then we will put the language model why
are we adding in language model because
because the acoustic model has only
meaning
about uh phonetics and or acoustics and
has no meaning or bag now our
background of language so this is
why we add a language model to give the
probability distribution over sequences
of words
given the context of the speech finally
we have as an output the transcripts
which are the written text we have the
hypothesis or predictions and the ground
truth or
the real text that we should compare
with
and at this stage we would like to
compare or to see how our model is
performing so we would like to use a
good metric
and the most known matrix that is used
for asr
is the where or the word error rate and
it calculates the
number of errors average it and we have
three types of errors
the first one is the substitution when
the
modal predicts a word while it
gets uh some errors in some characters
in the word and the
second error is the insertion when i i
don't say a word by the modal predicts
it and the last one the deletion which
is the
inverse when i don't when i say a word
and the model
does not predict and then we average by
the total number of words in the ground
truth
um i'll leave the stage for my colleague
appear now
thanks nurse and now we're going to
introduce some data sets which are
commonly known in for the asr
with arabic language let's talk about
few of them
we have mainly can you next slide please
thank you so uh we have three well-known
data sets
for the arabic language the first one is
the arabic speech corpus which is an msa
data set
for the standard arabic and consisting
of
3.7 hours the second one is cam and
voice arabic which is also an msa data
set consisting of 77
hours the third one is
the arabic research speech recognition
resources
which contains three three more than
three but
for the asr we have three data sets mgb2
mgb3 and mgb5
the first one is for the msa and some
dialects and
the second and third one are for
dialects for the mgb2 we have
101 000 sorry 200
hours for mgb3 we have 15 hours of
egyptian
recordings and for the moroccan data set
we have nearly 14 hours and for the
these last three data sets they are
mainly um
script from youtube and they they had
been
transcribed manually so
as you can see there is no lot of there
is not a lot of
resources which are public for the
arabic so
this is why we suggested to we try to
suggest
some techniques in order to collect your
own data set or
to augment it so for this suggestion we
would like to suggest
scraping audio files from our recordings
from youtube or other
or other resources and then you need to
segment audio files because
in general we work with audio files in
the range of
0 to 16 seconds just to avoid getting
some memory issues
and then we will need to transcribe them
and for the transcription we can
if there is a trained asr model even
with a low performance
you can use it to transcribe the
segmented audio files
and then you can double check the uh
or you will end up manually transcribing
them this is a good way to create your
own data set another way to
to enlarge your data set is by applying
data augmentation techniques
here we're going to cover a few of them
uh
basically these techniques could help
the model be more robust to many forms
of variations
such as adding noise to your data set
speed perturbation help with the model
to other other techniques sorry that
help the model to be more speaker
independent
such as modifying the speech and by
modifying the speech if you have
for example um a data set
for a male voice so and you would like
to have a data set that
contains voices for kids and
female-like voices so playing with the
pitch could help you to
have that kind of data set and vary your
data set
in the demo later on we will see some
examples of
these techniques so um
yeah let's move to the next slide so uh
then uh
in the next part we're going to
introduce a deep neural network
architecture for solving
uh a asr problem so i will let the floor
for
michael ignore shane to talk about this
um thank you abeer so
in the next slides we'll go um to
introduce one of the deep neural network
architecture for an acoustic model so
as you can see instagram that was
already created
and then we add some of convolutional
layers we can choose the number of
layers the way we want
and then on top of that we add recurrent
neural networks
and of course the number of layers
only we add a fully connected layer on
top of which we add the connection is
temporal classification or a cdc
so let's go into more details on how
this
actually works so as i said you have the
spectrogram
and then we should split it into simple
which are parts of the
let's say the image those are uh split
into
time oh time one until time n those are
the input of the cnn model
why did we choose a cnn because
convolutional neural networks have
proven efficiency
into extracting meaningful information
or features from the images and the
spectrogram can easily be seen as an
image
this is why cnn is a good option here
then we add these the rnn rnn are
known to be efficient for sequence
modeling and
here um when i am going to say a
character
or a word it mostly be likely be
dependent on the previous characters
that i said or the previous word that i
mentioned
so this is why we use the rnns and there
are multiple kinds of errors we can use
it could be jru's
lstms or even bi-directional gru's or
bi-directional lscms
and at the last step we add the ctc
which is a kind of
classification layer that will predict
or output all the possibility prediction
for each character
and the characters here are part of our
vocabulary which are the
uh arabic characters
etc adding to them the space so when i
don't say anything
the model should be predicting the space
and here uh for example for the uh our
same example algebraia tunisia the first
uh more likely
character to be predicted should be the
aleph then and
lamp etc enzo predicting the whole world
or
then the whole sentence
i leave this uh this stage for uh
so in this part we're going to talk
about a technique that could
enhance the performance of the acoustic
model
so let's move to the next slide please
so
uh the output of the acoustic model as
you can see
is the ctc matrix as we explained
earlier
which contained the probability of the
likelihood of each character at each
time step
as you can see this example here we took
an example where in our vocabulary we
have
mainly two uh two characters a and b
and the this is the blank token
and we have the in this matrix the
probability at each time step t
zero is the first time step and then we
have t one
at each time step we have the
probability of each character
and this is as we said this is the
output of the acoustic model
now the question is how could we use
this matrix in order to get our
transcriptions
here we can talk about two techniques
were two algorithms which are the
gradient search
and beam search decoding let's explain
them more in detail
for the greedy search for the first part
the greedy search mainly concatenates
most probable characters per time step
for t0 for example
we will look into the character which
has the highest probability in this
example
the character with the highest
probability is the nine character which
is nothing
so we will take it at uh then we will we
move to the
to uh t1 at t1 also the the most uh
probable character is blank so the
output of this matrix or the prediction
or the transcription
would be nothing using the credit agreed
search
algorithm now moving to the
bim search algorithm which is an a
well used strategy for dealing with
sequence to sequence kind of problems
and mainly this algorithm mainly creates
iteratively text candidates
as we explained for the greedy search we
take the best path at each time step we
take
only the most probable characters but
when it comes to bim search we're going
to
um extract uh the top k
candidates we will not end up having
only
one sequence with the most high the
highest probabilities
will have k candidates and the k is the
beam width
we specify the beam width how many
candidates you would like to have at the
end
and it works as follows you will explain
it through this
tree so initially we don't have anything
always we are using the same matrix here
which contains the probabilities
initially we don't have anything at the
first stage at t
0 we have three possible characters a b
and nothing we will put them
all and we will just keep the two
best um candidates which are uh
a and nothing we will move to the
t1 the next stage and we will do the
same thing
and keep the two best uh candidates
so uh in the t1 we have
in this the first node we have a
then we have we can add after a
b or a or nothing and for the other node
as well we have nothing and after
nothing we could have
a b and nothing and we calculate here at
this stage the conditional probability
and then we could decide to take the
most probable
uh sequences yeah and we iterate
like this uh over all the time steps in
order to get finally the um
k candidates so this is the main
difference between greedy search would
give which gives
us only one candidate with the best path
and the bim search
gave us k candidates so what's the
problem
with these algorithms for
both greedy search and beam search
decoding
we use the output of the acoustic model
which
may not understand the context and tense
sometimes to make some
uh spelling and like linguistic errors
and also it's it will find it uh as a
an acoustic model it will find it hard
to distinguish between
homophones even for a human if we
i would say uh asa which may mean
disobey or
a piece of wood they are written
differently
and uh if i don't give you the context
you will not uh
end up you will not uh understand what
do i mean
i mean a verb or i mean uh i i i meant
a name so given the context will uh
probably will um
will improve the results of the model
so this is why we try to
add a language model on top of the
acoustic model in order to give some
context
and try to improve the performance of
the acoustic model
so mainly the language model is trained
on a massive text corpora
and the standard approach for the asr is
using engram language models
and there are some techniques who relies
on
transformers in this presentation we're
going to talk only
about the engram models
for the ingram models mainly you can
train them using
knlm which is an open source uh
library uh and yes let's now take
uh let's see how we can fuse the beam
search decoding with the language model
as we said before the bim search will
output k candidates
and for each candidate we have a score
from the
which is the probability of the sequence
from the acoustic model
apart from this we will add another
score which is related to the language
model so the language model will
attribute a score
for the each candidate and the final
score would be
a combination between the acoustic score
language model score and the sequence
length and we have some
tunable parameters which are alpha and
beta you can choose them
to get better results best performance
i mean in terms of word array
let's now move to a comparison between
the um to have an idea about uh the bim
search decoding beam surf plus language
model decoding and
the agreed search we have always the
same
example which is uh
so for this example we have
we this is the first table sorry is the
output of the beam search decoding plus
language model
this is the final score the first column
is the final score and then we have the
three candidates
uh the best one is the first the
highlighted one
and we have highlighted some difference
between the ground truth and
the predictions as you can see here in
the ground truth
the number 25
was written in digits but for the
language model
would it would find it hard to predict
numbers
and he uh only learned to
um transcribe words the way he
hear it or yeah so uh this is why the
output here
you can find it written in the
characters alhamdusi
another thing is july for
july uh he will not write it in
latin characters because the uh the
model we have
was trained on arabic letters so would
not recognize
other characters which are not in its
vocabulary
so for the comparison comparison in the
next table between the greedy search and
being search language model decoding
there is a major difference here between
the greedy search
and beam search language model decoding
in the
in the word july
for the world july for the greedy search
he has
write it or transcribe it the way he uh
we pronounce it so he writes in july
but when we use the language model
infusion with the
acoustic model you can see here that
july was transformed
or it uh it gives a favor to
yulio because you is
is part of its vocabulary of the
vocabulary of the language model
so he will prioritize words that
are in its vocabulary so
mainly the language model are
can it can be used to um correct some
spelling characters and
improve very well the performance of the
acoustic model
but when it comes to other vocabulary
words it
it's really um so the the language model
will not tend to give good results for
out of vocabulary words
so yeah this is it now we have covered
the
theoretical part it's time to move to
the practical part
so i pass over the speech to norshan to
talk about to introduce the demo
thank you albert so can you see the
jupiter notebook now
okay so uh here we go so in this jupiter
notebook we will be using tensorflow to
create
uh an asr system based on dnns so there
will be three major steps the first step
is to pre-process
our data which is some kind of uh or a
massive
uh input of acoustic mode acoustic or
voice recorded and then the second step
would be
to create the architecture of the model
uh
the same that we introduced in the uh
presentation a cnn plus
an arrogant plus a ctc decoder and in
the final step
we will train actually the model then
find and then um run some interference
on uh some unseen data
and here we go so let's start with the
first step here in the pre-processing or
the transformation of the data set we'll
be using mainly two packages
the librosa and the pi audio which are
built-in modules for some basic audio
functionalities
we start by importing the librosa and we
need the path of the audio file which is
the same file we used in the
uh the presentation we special specify
the
sample rate and simple rate is actually
the number of
points or values that we are going to
take into consideration
from the uh wav file it's a way of
transforming
a wav file into numpy arrays and we load
the data so the type is actually
numpy.nd
array then here we would like to see the
audio duration we use also blue browser
so the it's about
nine seconds the total number of samples
is calculated by
the sample rate multiplied by the
duration of the audio file
and overall we have more than 155
um samples or points or which is
coincides with the
um or the dimension of the tensor
representing the audio file
here we can
[Music]
python display that displays the audio
file in jupiter notebooks
we would like also to see the amplitude
in function of time
we use two libraries the libros are also
the matplotlib for
plots and we can display uh here the
wave plot and we see
the amplitudes variating from negative
to positive values
in terms of time and here we have nine
seconds which
is the overall size or duration of the
audio file
then we would like to transform the
audiophile into a spectrogram and
uh the libroza actually has the
implementation of the algorithm of the
tff
we introduced in the presentation so we
just have to call the
method uh libroset.stft to transform the
wave
into a plot of uh hertz here represents
the frequency
in terms of time and the frequencies
varies also from negative to positive
values and the negative actually here
the blue ones
are mainly those that humans can not
hear so the main information are hidden
here uh somewhere that we should be able
then to extract
to have the uh final transcripts
uh we introduced also in the
presentation some kind of a data
augmentation in case the data is not
sufficient enough
here we use two major um python packages
that we should pip install the wave
augment and the nl uh
part so we just have to pip install them
and then
um call them in a cell
and we transform our um our audiophile
into a torch audio
and finally we can start with the first
type of augmentation which is adding
noise
so first we should generate the noise
with which is a mathematical function
and then we add this generated audio
or this generated noise to our uh
voice which is the x and we can hear it
using the ipg
audio
so you can hear here a background noise
that was generated and added to the
audio file
then the second type of augmentation in
the speed perturbation
first one is the speed down we should
use a factor between
0 and 1 add it to our audio file and
here after you can hear the result
and in case we would like to have a
speed up we should
choose exactly the same function just
changing the factor to a number between
or a tuple between one and two and we
apply it and we can hear
hear the results
okay there is also two other types or
one type that could be modified is
the modification of the pitch it could
be a peach up
when we use a factor a positive factor
and we apply it we get this result
so this is a more kind of a kid's
voice if our data is not representing
kid voice enough
and in the pitch down we use the same um
we can choose the same number but in a
negative way and we get this output
so this is more like an old man
or um an old a woman or a male uh
voice so i'll keep now the i'll
let abir continue on the same jupiter
notebook
uh thanks nurse and so in this part
we're going to go through uh
the and implement a tensorflow
implementation of an asr model
uh for to recognize uh the arabic speech
we will just go through the basic steps
in order to help you
understand the different steps to create
an asr model so as the first step
we are we need to prepare our data set
we need to specify just the path of our
data set with the csv file using pandas
as you can see here in our data set we
have two columns the path of the audio
files and then the
transcriptions you can see here that the
transcriptions are written in backwater
uh you can uh have the transcriptions in
arabic script or
a backwater buckwalter is just a
character map
from arabic to latin characters
you can see here an example uh we use
language
length trans in order to convert
backwater into
arabic a script here is an example
uh yeah for for our case we are going to
use the transcriptions in buckwalter
for the modeling part we are going to
use a deep
asr implementation of deep speech 2
a deep speed deep asr story is an open
source implementation of different
automatic speech recognition
architectures it supports
mainly to architectures they use deep
speech too and deep asr network
the model architecture we are going to
talk
to use uh in our case is deep speech
architecture we have just
explained uh throughout the presentation
so we are not going to dig deeper into
explaining the different the
architecture
let's talk about the input of the model
as you can see the input is the
spectrogram so it's
it's something like this which is demand
spectrogram
the so we have uh 161 which is
uh mainly used when conventionally used
when using is
a sample rate of 60 kilohertz in our
case we are using sample rate of 16
kilohertz
and the x-axis is the time
so for each record we could have
different times each one has its own
duration
so for the deep asr package that we are
going to work with
doesn't support arabic so we made some
changes in order to make it
work with arabic language so
first of all we need to configure our
pipeline
we need to specify what kind of features
or what kind of feature we're going
we're going to use as input for our
model in our case we're going to use
spectrogram
and then we need to specify the
vocabulary
you just need to specify the language in
our case
we we added the arabic language to the
scripts in order to recognize the arabic
to get the arabic characters in our case
the alphabet would be
the back quarter characters uh then
we need to specify the dimension of the
input output to our model
uh yeah you need just to call the
get model get deep speech
or if you would like to use the other
model which is
deep asr network you just call the model
which is implemented in the package
specify the input output to your model
and
then you we need as a
another step to put
to choose the optimizer in our case we
choose to work with the default
optimizer which is adam optimizer you
need to set your
hyper parameters then you uh
for this packet for this package also
there is um we can we have the choice to
use either
a greedy search decoder or bim search
decoder with the language model
so we choose to work with the greedy
search
and then yeah all right you need to set
the pipeline
you put it all together and then you
start
the training as simple as that just call
the pipeline
fit and gives it the training data set
and the batch size and the number of
epochs
this is the summary of the model the
same architecture we explained before
for yeah for the sake of this demo we
didn't use a large data set
and we just took a sample from
mgb2 dataset which is a an msa dataset
in order to make the pipeline work on an
arabic language
and to show you the whole pipeline from
building the model and to testing the
model on the real use cases
so here are
we can move to the second part which is
the model testing or the interference
where we can make uh some predictions so
here is an example so
yeah the highlighted one is the
reference and
the prediction of the model is uh
in this cell yeah the highlighted one
right now
so uh as you can see uh the as we said
sorry before
the we used a sample of the data to make
the demo work for
the arabic language and for the deep
speech
deep speech architecture they mentioned
in their paper that they need a large
enough data set in order to get
good enough results they have trained
for english for example
on around 11k hours
in order to get good results so for
our case if you would like to work with
this architecture
so make sure you need to have a large
enough data set
or there are other techniques that you
can use either transfer learning
uh you can take you can take for example
a model which
was trained on another language and fine
tune it on your
uh task if you don't have enough data
so yeah mainly this is it let's move to
the conclusion so i pass over the speech
to
norshan um thank you adi for this demo
it was very useful i hope it was useful
for any
everyone everyone here also so in this
presentation we presented what asr is we
went through some of its
main challenges and data sets that you
can use for arabic and
low resources languages that are north
african dialects
we built a dna model on top of which we
can add a language model to improve its
performance
but this is um just an introduction for
this asr
field i for those who are really um
want to to to learn more about this
build i really
recommend you to learn more and um
about the new techniques such as
transfer learning and fine tuning and
maybe read some of the latest research
papers talking about
models based on transformers such as the
wave touvec
also more complicated architecture based
on convolution neural networks
architectures such as quartz net or
situation
so this was the full presentation i hope
that we have still
time yes 15 minutes for a q a session
yeah
thank you thank you so we have
some questions can you uh how can you
tunisian asr model understand that
potluck
and what are the same words pronounced
speakers of different regions
yeah mainly you need to have a data set
which is which contains this difference
the
acoustic model will try to uh
to uh transcribe the speech the way he
uh he uh hear it so
if you have a data set which contains
different accents
it will help very much the asr model to
distinguish between the different
accents
yeah perfect thank you for the awesome
presentation
you mentioned that adding the di critics
expected to improve the sr model
accuracy
by adding diacritics might
make the recognition more challenging
since each one will be considered as
different symbol in the dictionary also
every similar word with different
diacritics would be considered as
different word and
increase the dictionary which may not
have enough representation in the data
um yeah so adding uh diacritics
uh is very helpful in the case that
it will add more information about how
we are pronouncing certain words
and yes if we add a critics they are
going to be
uh considered as other parts of
dictionary especially if you are working
with
a buck walter because each um
is considered as a different character
and this is going to augment the
vocabulary it may augment the
comp the need of more computational
resources
but um especially if we are going to use
more dataset for this but it could
improve the results yeah so
you you have to to choose between
augmenting uh
the data or the uh the vocabulary size
for a
better performance or keeping
lower vocabulary for lower performance
okay so uh next question
first thank you for this amazing
presentation then i want to ask you
about the steps and some tips to create
an asr project
i think we already talked about that
during the demo and
throughout the session okay
do you think uh extracting mfcc
is enough as a feature to help with the
sr
or is it better to use multiple features
so um actually we
were using mfcc in the um
all the let's say architectures not
necessarily using deep neural network
but basically using statistical
um neural network statistical models but
when adding the
neural networks especially when using
the cnn model
the saner architecture it actually
replaces this one
as it has the ability to extract useful
features from the images
thank you how do you segment words
characters for the model input and what
dsp techniques
have you tested besides fft and spectre
yeah in our case you worked on a
character level but yeah for sure you
can use other segmentation techniques
such as the spe
and wpe where the level
uh word level um segmentation or
subwords tokenization but yeah it could
generally improve the results
uh for example the model that we showed
in the last part is citronette it works
with
the spe and wpe and shows shown has
shown a
really good performance when working on
sub-token
level okay next question
thank you for this nice work do you
think transfer learning
from a standard arabic model would be
helpful to create a new model for some
arabic dialect
i think it's a great act a great
question actually because uh yeah it
definitely could and
it has it is showing to to we are
actually working on something similar so
it's uh showing great results
yeah the main idea is to take the
encoder part as
when we pronounce words we are actually
pronouncing
different characters but the outputs or
the the
the vocabulary or the decoder parts
would change
and when pronouncing words there are a
lot of similarities between the standard
arabic or the msa a between
the dielectrical so the idea of using
transformer
learning from standard arabic model to a
dialectal model is um a great idea even
even doing transfer learning from
another language even from english to
arabic
has proven great results so yeah it
definitely is
uh thank you machen so next question dsp
uh math takes a lot of time what advice
for beginners to get up and
running quickly with asr
yeah you can basically start with
the demo that we have shown right now it
will
help you to understand the basic steps
for building an asr model
and then you can start improving the
model architecture adding some
techniques like we have shown
just now adding the language model and
yeah thank you so last question
mf cc spec 2 and mfcc coefficient
coefficients are different
what are the best
questions yeah i don't know
mfcc expect to add mfcc coefficients
are different what are the best what can
text
i didn't get any question okay
so i i don't think we have other
questions so
thank you very much thank you abeer and
roshan and
let's take a break for 10 minutes and we
will be back
we will be back with the third talk
thank you very much
you can stay on the on the
on the meet basically um
and we'll be back in about 10 minutes
thank you
welcome back everyone welcome thank you
zarya uh welcome to everyone to our
third
uh talk text to speech with tensorflow
our speakers who are with us uh
amel salemi and khalid homa from
instagram
uh amel is a research engineering
athlete
a google developer expert in machine
learning officially a mentor at the
google for startup in the middle east
north africa region and was and was a
host of the open mind
minded ask me anything session she was
invited and sponsored by facebook to
take part in the f8 hackathon
and conference she is a volunteer
speaker in various events like gtx
google for mana deep learning in dub she
has a software engineer by engineering
background
acquired from the national school of
computer science
onsie in tunisia khalil homage
then studied as an intern and then
continued as an ai research engineer
he specializes in natural language
processing
by by working on the latest advances in
this field
khalil is more focused on applying these
technology technologies
to the arabic language to help boost the
arabic community for more digitalization
so welcome to khalil and uh and aman
and the stage is yours
thank you for your intro so uh
just let me quit sharing
so i think screen share right
yes we can see it okay thank you
yes uh he said we will uh introduce you
uh today the text-to-speech um
thank you for your attendance and i hope
that you'll uh satisfy from our
presentation today
uh starting with the outline uh first we
will begin with the introduction
and then we will speak about the ts
pipeline how the tts
really works and after that we'll speak
about the model uh
evolution of pts and
we will the timeline of the dts model
and after that we will list we will list
some challenges
and next step in this field then
we will speak about the tensorflow uh
what's new in the tensorflow
and updates and finally we will conclude
the quick demo that will showcase our
topic so starting with introduction
about the text speech which is uh
also called a speech synthesis of
operation tts
actually what is it it is really it is
the artificial
production of the immune human voice so
for example giving this text in arabic
salman alaikum the case model will
convert
this text into a wave format
and there is some
measurement for the quality of the
studio the first is the how
natural in this audio which means how it
is close to the human speech and
the intelligibility which means how it
is understandable
uh for us how this study is
understandable for
humans so this topic it is actually have
some
several use cases uh it is originally
designed
to help people with disabilities
especially the ones that have some
visual difficulties
lately lately it is used in
different sectors like uh transfer
travel
and healthcare advertising and other
sectors
and especially if it is used in
the assistant like the ai like the uh
conversational ai and chatbots and
it is frequently used lately
uh for these uh feelings
so about the dts so now
we uh actually how how do computers can
process our voice uh first of all the
sound signal is made by a variation in
the air pressure
so this air pressure we could measure
this uh
sound signal by measuring the intensity
of this pressure
and actually it is a series of numbers
uh series of members that called could
illustrate our signal
for example this is um a shot
of the uh of the real of a real south
side
signal which is the amplitude against uh
time
so this basically this spot is made
with three different frequencies
so if we want to plot these frequencies
in the frequency domain which means
in an amplitude against a frequency
blood in just a strict interval time
it's called spectrum spectrum need
is uh could represent the same signal
but in frequency domain
and after that if we want to vary this
spectrum over time
we'll have the final spectrogram
representation
which will give also which
will represent also our sound signal in
another way which is
a frequency over time and we could
could get information about the
intensity intensity of
and amplitude by the new colors so it is
a 3d
3d plot and working with
spectrogram is very beneficial because
it is as an image that represents
sounds will be used with the cnn
and will make a very very useful
information about our sounds so speaking
about
frequency actually the human does not
receive frequency
in linear way so differ in the the human
ear
does not receive frequency in linear way
which means
that we are more sensitive to difference
between uh lower frequencies then higher
one for example taking this example
the two uh first frequencies uh the
difference we could easily distinguish
the difference between them but if we
want to to move to a higher frequency
although is the the same difference
between them but we will hardly
distinguish the difference between these
two
frequencies to speak about the male
spectrogram
the match spectrogram it is a conversion
made for the
just a normal spectrogram which is a
linear spectrogram as you see
as you see the number spectronomic is a
linear spectrogram in terms of frequency
so so the male and
so that the spectrogram will be will
manage to
to deal with our with the non-linearity
of this pregnancy that we just spoke
about and it and it is tend to give more
information
and uh beneficial for the working
working with yes working with yes models
so now we could uh after speaking about
the frequency and
spectrogram we could now move to the
plate line
[Music]
so uh for our input so we have the text
and audio uh the corresponding audio of
this text
uh we only told you uh just your
training so remove this input and pass
to our spectrogram module where the
spectrum
where the spectrogram model will train
and
give us output with a prediction of the
spectrogram of the audio
after that we will remove the
spectrogram
degenerate it's expected onto another
model called the content this recorder
is a generator of the final wave audio
symbol
so these two uh these two models are
separately trained uh from each other
so for the first first phase which is
the data
reprocessing uh we should eventually we
should have
you know test the text from especially
from the uh
foreign language world and some and
extra spaces
and other special characters because it
is uh
it will impact our training and
lead to some uh low performance for the
generated audio also it is better and
recommended to use
phonemes because volume scripts
tend to give more information about how
the
world really pronounce it so it is
highly recommended to use it
instead of just raw text also there are
some
quality checks for your checks that you
could make for your data set do you
to have a good performance and increase
your model uh output performance
like uh we should have a balance between
audio clip
duration and text length because if we
have uh
because we have too long uh text
and with a short very short flip this
will be interesting this will affect
our training and will lead to very very
uh
uh we need to very low performance
in terms of audio quality also we could
measure the
measure the noise level in other in our
audio clips and try to remove the noisy
one
because tts
another thing uh we could find the best
audio pure processing parameters
that fit our data because uh we know the
recorded data
is different differentiable from a
speaker to another
from the male 2 or female so we could
tune this parameter that to have a very
good uh
audio quality and another thing we could
uh for better uh also better
audio processing we could convert our
our
audio to sample rate assemble rate
between 60k hertz and
the 20k knobs after
our data set we could move the second
phase which is
generating the spectrogram so our
inspector can be the system composed
of recurrent uh sequence to sequence uh
prediction this uh network uh used
this network um train
this network would map the character
embedding and
uh to generate email spectrogram so
uh because it is sequence to sequence uh
network the encoder there is encoder
handycoder the encoder reads
character step by step and try to output
a status vector after that the
encoder decoder will get all these
status vectors and will generate
spectrogram frames step by step
so for the training uh goal for this
phase
for this model a training
goal is to achieve the best alignment
possible between
between the encoder and this alignment
will
will give an intuition about how uh how
well the trend
is our model is and uh if we could if we
get
a clean alignment like this it means
that the the model is
well trained and could give a very and
give a very uh clean uh audio and high
performance
audio symptoms this is an example of the
predicted
spectrogram but for example if we have
this
if we have this uh this alignment which
which which as you see that that has
some uh
diffracted part and uh the the alignment
is not
clear at all at all this is either it is
it is um just in the first steps of the
training or
the model in our data and it is facing
some problems
dealing with the data it may be caused
by the
as we said by the noise or not the
outline
outlier in our data or
[Music]
after generating the spectrogram model
now we could
uh make our audio by the in the first
phase interface to continue
model which is as i said the trainable
model
it is trained separately from the
other one from the spectral model so the
code
is to convert the metal spectrogram
feature presentation into time domain
waveform
and generate the final audio symbols uh
these recorder models
exist in different architectures such as
with the convolutional network
neural network with the gun airmen and
others
so to test actually to test the this
model performance
but we could i just listened to the
audio
and try to to see how natural it is
to
[Music]
how the how the model will perform how
the model is performing
in our uh another thing
i would uh mention and they would you uh
take a idea for it is the
if it is that some
some environment uh
in practical or uh that does not support
the arabic text so
how could we use these output phrases
how we could solve this problem and uh
and
and make a tts uh model from the arab
text
uh and for unfortunately uh there is a
form of called backwater which is
developed uh
to represent uh the arabic uh
script by just converting it to
latin uh script for example if we have
this
uh text ceremony after conversion we
will um
we will get this uh the conversion
and will uh easily represent the
represent the
arabic text and and uh the thing is
it is very easy to just have to
our without any issue
or any problem but if we have a
diplomatized
text i have a text with the skill how we
can solve this
issue unfortunately the quota is
it supports the the depletization
and we'll give the another
representation uh
with more information for this for this
text
and uh just to bring your rotation
because
this mistake will will give us more
information about
how the this world will be pronounced
and it is
hardly recommended to uh highly
recommended to use
this dedicated performance because we'll
it will increase the motor performance
and
help the model to deal
to know more about our language
so after that now we could uh
speak about the sound evolution for the
tts
field uh the test model starts from the
15 by the
electronic devices and then with some
basic models like a concatenate and
formant uh
synthesized model then some basic uh
statistical uh model like human base and
finally
uh the deep learning based
uh synthesized moment uh so uh
we will look through some just some very
the
big uh big point in this timeline for
example we start with the concatenative
concatenated
tts the competence is based on just
concatenating the segments of recorded
speech
so uh for example if we have this word
hello
and the the the funny script
correspond to this world uh and after
that
if we bring this just broke this phoneme
and try to have some record
recordings for these uh separated
phonemes
so now we have database that contain uh
separated
that referred to each phoneme so if we
combine these
uh these recorded recording recorded
videos short videos we we could have
this uh
the word that you want and uh
our uh our speech uh this is a just
basic example for which with the word
but about
real life the concatenate concatenated
has a very
very large database containing words and
other stuff recorded the bad thing is
that
for the drawbacks for this model it is
very very time for
strong because have a large database and
wants to
retrieve each unit small unit of sound
recorded in the database also it reduced
very very low natural sound and
have a reported robotic sound in the
rated speech another thing uh
came up in the ttts timeline is the
hmm-based
services which is called also a
statistical professional
based on hidden markov models the
the idea is that this model uh
uh try to learn and approximate the
parameters that could make speech
parameters such as a fundamental
frequency and spectrum funny duration
and other
that make speech so after combining the
the
module try to combine this parameter and
process them
so it can generate a final speech
and after that the deep learning based
models come up with the wavenet which is
the
one of the first determining based model
for the gts
for dts topic uh actually it is a big
big uh
big event that happened in the tts
history
and uh it was written by the deep
mind google's team in september 2016.
so so the webinar is learning mobile
based on the convolutional networks
uh the the it requires
that it doesn't just work with just the
wrong text because it needs some
extra and some intermediate uh
pre-processing from its front-end so it
works with
linguistic features not just our text so
after
uh giving the these language language
linguistic features
to the model the model will try to learn
and
produce some uh produce the voice
related voicemail
with with the real audio form so
what this model have actually benefited
this model that is produced some
much more uh natural sounding speech
in compared to the different part of the
previous
statistical and simple models so the
training
as i said uh giving a simple uh
just one second of uh uh of audio clip
and
some linguistic features uh the model
will uh be conditioning on this picture
and try to predict
the audio sample if i actually try to
predict each point
is simple in this in this wave form
so after that some mode would be some
models
were inspired from this wavenet
model like detectron which is the
spectrogram uh
generator model and this model was
was built with the sequence to sequence
network with retention
uh it worked it has include the text and
audio pair
and try to uh and train it from uh
from scratch so the the uh this model
after training uh it tried to map
the character into internet to
just not be character into spectrogram
frames
and the spectrogram here was just a
linear spectrogram not female
1 so and after this spectrum
uh model 2 uh based on
this model was uh built because they
they have some they they make they they
made some
changes to the architecture of some
improvements
also this model was trained from
trend with the speech and its
corresponding uh transcripts
the audio and the text corresponding
text
the improvement was maybe the the layer
hidden in the
layer of the model the the benefit
also of this model is that it is that
to predict female spectrum gram it works
with
the recorder which means we can we can
uh
give this uh spectrogram as input to the
recorder model in our case they use uh
they used
the wavenet uh we saw previously
which will convert this program into uh
into wave samples
another thing you could use these these
ml program with the graphene
algorithm this algorithm will produce
so now we could list some
challenges and next steps in
this tedious field for example
uh the difficulties with some words that
are not seen before even
the the deep learning based model
make a big big change in the
history but we we still
face some difficulties with the the
non-seen words and
difficult words in our in our data
also uh there is some difficulty of
including
the vocal expression like someone if it
is someone happy or sad or not
this is still a challenging task uh
and even for the determining basic model
so it's still
still under the research also um this
mod
type of model especially the attacker it
is very very heavy motion
so we still cannot yet generate
the audio in real time because
it has some very very heavy uh model and
help someone have many billion
parameters
uh another thing uh speaking about the
int
and tts model we didn't yet we
still haven't yet any end-to-end model
that generate an audio directly from the
text not
with some some inter
some
[Music]
other mobile components and
another topic another issue in gta's
topic is the code switching or the
language alternative so for example
for the example for the spoken english
word
there are some french words that
included in the
in the text in english text when people
spoke english
so how the model will uh will learn
these three french words and try to
uh as a
french word so it will it have to
to pronounce it as a native french not
an english word and now
i could pass the award to my
league i meant to continue presentation
great thank you khalid very much
i will try to share my screen
from here um
okay okay i have i hope
everyone is able to see this
uh i will try to talk here in arabic
sometimes here in arabic and sometimes
in
english i hope you can hear my voice
so uh just a quick overview
in a general in a in a general manner uh
i think one of the most important things
nowadays in compu
i mean in natural language processing is
trying to understand the different parts
that we can use uh in an application
how to create an end-to-end application
using natural language processing
there are different types uh the first
part that hadam and
malik talked about here well partly
related to sentiment analysis
it can be in tunisian uh dialect using
transformers and all these kind of
things
the second part was talking about uh
asar which is basically trying
automatic speech recognition
we have an audio the dana audio and we
try to to
generate the text of it it's like
understanding
uh it's like people when when they chat
and
second one is uh the one that we are
trying to
uh to present to you today and i
which is basically having an audio and
uh having a text actually and we're
trying to generate
an audio we have the text
and the steps from this text we're
trying to generate an audio
or spectrogram and this is uh basically
the whole idea of
of the uh this tensorflow makeup as i
won't try to sum up
uh to sum it up okay
because it's tensorflow of course uh one
of the things uh one of the most
important things to talk about
of course is tensorflow so um
uh what's what's new with tensorflow in
2021
it's part of the google i o uh uh
introduction
uh so so you can find uh oh you can find
all this detail online
anime there is there is no nothing that
we can we can add about it al sheikh
tensorflow when when when is used
actually
uh it's there is different parts the
first part is that tensorflow a
tensorflow is more used for for
production yanni and stamina tensorflow
because there are different kind of
models
that are being are being used and we
have like different kind of
uh architectures that can be uh later on
uh
yani and istanbul production and when we
talk about production like applications
uh
right nowadays in these times we use it
every day we use it on facebook we use
it with twitter we use it like i don't
know everywhere everywhere there is uh
ai and everywhere there is
like uh models that uh that are
put into production and this is the goal
actually i think uh so so basically uh
one of the tensorflow's
um important things is that okay let me
try to
put the cursor okay one of the
tensorflow important
major uh let's say difference between
tensorflow
1.0 and tensorflow 2 is that uh having
all the
apis together
when we talk about tensorflow uh
tensorflow 1.0 there was like different
bunch of apis
different apis with country slim uh
executors uh estimators and all these
can and keras of course
and it was very very hard to have a
global vision on which model or which
api to use for for production so one of
the things that
made a huge leap in in tensorflow 2.0
it's like me
making things easier for for python
developers using keras so the major
improvement is that keras was like
invented or
let's say created by francois and it was
like
and he outsourced it in the uh for for
the community and this
and in this part uh 2.0 was created
using uh keras the the different the
difference between all these kind of
models is that
all of them uh like the difference
between all this kind of sorry um
version is that the first one was easier
as uh
having easier python development for the
making
making it easy sorry the second one is
supporting tpus and all these kind of
things
uh the 2.0 2.2 sorry profiling tools
adding profiling management
yani when you have different models
and you try to find the best one the
best hyper parameters and all these kind
of things in
related to it bader uh the 2.3
had better data management improvements
2.4 updating the distribution of
training using parallel gpus and all
these kind of details
and 2.5 is like adding quality and
stability and
uh pain and habitat quality uh
using research improving the research in
the communities
with with tensorflow uh with tensorflow
okay uh so so what's the what's the
major uh
important as i think uh announcements
that google uh was done by google at
google i o is like the first one is dave
extended which is basically uh you have
uh
we have you have like a platform it's a
paid platform um yani um
it's not free and this platform is used
for production
ml enterprise at scale so so you can you
can have like
backfield fixing issues uh can be
helping in back fixing issues can be
helping giving you google cloud
uh profound platforms and all this this
kind of
details that can help leverage your
production
uh using google uh with with tensorflow
extended
uh the second thing and i think uh
one of these um things is that it's
responsible ai
uh yani uh unresponsible ai and i think
in tunisia we we don't talk enough about
it
and responsible ai meaning that you
first need to know what's in your data
there is like something called know your
data and it means like you know the bias
the gender can be gender-based any uh
female male and or these kind of things
well um yani uh having apis that help
you understand
how much your model is private for
example yanni and privacy parts
fairness part how fair is this
putting a production a model in a
production
and putting a model in real life it's
not an easy uh thing
and we have also we have always
experienced some kind of
uh weird like for example facebook
telling you that this
is uh this is very harmful or something
like that and this is part of the
responsible ai
kind of thing and which is really
important to know and
and understand the last part
is tensorflow for mobile and web which
is basically uh trying to
to say uh we have like the tensorflow
lite
uh runtime will be bundled with google
play services
um before one of the things that were
will be uh we're being able uh or
was there is that you have to uh to add
the run time uh the tensorflow lite
runtime before putting your application
into google play it's not the case
anymore because google play
provides it for you so it makes like
having a
low um size kind of applications uh for
for your model if you want to have a
model which is for production
and the second one is that you can now
run tensorflow lite models on the web
directly there there is a bunch of apis
uh the the tensorflow lite models and
that you can use with tensorflow.js or
something like that
and it's really interesting in a sense
that uh it
can help like in different kind of
things uh
let's try to go to the demo uh which is
the last part
of our uh of our
talk today uh i hope you are still able
to
hear me uh okay
this is was this was taken from the
tensorflow ttes
uh kind of uh you know github so so
everything you can find
in the audio samples the uh
there is also a very basic korean a
collab version if you want to try it out
so all you have to do is go to tensor
speech
github i o tensorflow test
one of the uh models that was
implemented and and
developed by uh by uh
google okay uh when we talk about sensor
speech or tensorflow details
which is it really it's a real-time
state-of-the-art speech synthesis
which is a tekatron application uh have
like different architectures
yanni tacotron 2 mel gun multiband
multiband mel gun fast speech
pistol uh we will try to see these
different models and
uh in in a very uh
very easy way janice and how
and we can speed up the training and
interference process and we will see
an example uh with uh in
in english so so it it won't be in
arabic
uh but it will be in english and i think
it's really interesting to see
the results of uh putting a um
and the results out of it in a
we have a model which is used to
generate a
spectrogram from text and there is uh
so the first part is that we have a text
we have a text
and then we try to generate a male
spectrogram from it
the second part is that from the smell
spectrogram we're trying to generate the
audio
anina we we do have two stages
and at the end uh the end of
and approach to uh this is the end to
end approach to generate audio from from
from text so it's like two times uh not
uh directly which is still under uh
research as khalil
uh talked uh before uh
i think uh the conquest that is part
uh as hale uh talked about it
which is like uh relies on highly
quality audio clips recording
uh which exists in in research right now
uh and the different kind of two phases
that it has and then
uh what's the i think it's the first
part
when they would when we were trying to
create uh or or to generate
a concatenate like uh tensorflow that is
uh or uh sorry uh generative uh
speech uh and the the highest
or the pros is that it gives high
quality and the possibility to prepare
to preserve the original actor's voice
and becomes is that
it's time consuming there is the
pipeline of trying to
find the features in a way is very time
consuming
a second part yani process uh
in this whole process we have also the
parametric
tts which is basically the goal is to
address the limitation of the
concatenates as
using statistical approaches like the
hidden markov chain
the hidden markov's model source
which is basically you have a first step
which is the the text is processed to
extract
uh linguistic features and the second
step is to
uh requires extraction of decoder
features
uh when we talk about the coder recorder
was the second part of our process so
the first part is generating a
spectrogram with
with the model and the second part uh we
generate from the spectrogram
an audio and this uh model we call it a
golder or something like that decoder
models
pros it's that it increases naturalness
voice our results uh looks natural and
not robotic the problem with with
generating speech
is that most of them what most of them
sounds like
it's like a robot talking and which is
very hard
uh to uh to avoid at the first early
stages for example
and the second um
so so what's the best part of of having
uh
of parametric uh like tts uh with for
example
uh hmm it's like encouraging increase uh
increasing sorry the naturalness uh the
cons is that
we have a lower quality of audio and the
voice can sound very uh robotic in a way
okay and
okay uh so so we said there are three
types
the first part is the concatenate the
second part
is the uh parameter models and then
there was
like the uh using deep learning models
to generate the
uh to extract the the features from uh
from the text that we have
first of all is like a very basic
approach
first of all what we try to do is to
install everything
we import the the the system we
import we we clone the github tensor
speech
and then uh we we added to our path
uh which is uh already done and then we
install actually uh the german
transliterate
this is back actually from their side uh
because
uh this uh they have a bunch of
german like uh models
that they can use that you can use to to
for example for german
chinese or anything else but this is
this was
for the general translator it is used
for german and
you have to install it if you want to
use the tensor uh
dancers uh tts and then we import the
hash five uh py version for uh
our uh checkpoints okay um a
goal of this um demo
to see the difference between the
different models that we have the
tacotron's fat speech
fast speech two uh and the different v
coders
yanni melgan everything uh
all of them we will all the recorders
will be based on the mel gun
uh sorry about this all of them will be
uh
based on the mel gun and and there is
different uh
kind of um let's say versions of this
mel gun uh
part and which is the the coder part and
we will listen together uh
to uh to it okay
the so so basically what we do it
is we everything is uh all these models
were
already pre-trained and we all we got to
do is doing interference
and we're going to test these models
that are was already uh trained on
english
uh for in in our case so
if we try to explain in a nutshell
um
a non-autograph feed forward convolution
architecture so it has a very basic
convolution architecture
you have the mass spectrogram so we're
talking about the decoder which is the
second part
right if you still uh if you're still
with me so basically we have a mass
spectrogram
we have convolution layers and then we
have we try to do
an input sequence which is a basically
delay uh
deleted convolution blocks and then
we uh we get our results so so this is
the basic architecture of the
uh generator the uh the
the discriminator part is just basically
you have a row
uh waveform and we try uh to do
a discriminator block and then
you you get some features uh feature
maps plus output and then you average
pool
uh these uh this uh
this results
as the name says it's a gun
architecture yani uh this generative
adversary network
architecture will uh generative
adversarial network i'm not sure if
you're familiar with it or not
um it uses two types of models
we have two models
which is called a generator it generates
uh
in in this case spectrograms uh will
it can be for example in images generate
images to try to fool
any uh fooling the discriminator and
this
discriminators try to uh will be fed
yani
uh we will give him the generators
output
and the real data that we have and we
try
uh to train the model in a way that the
generator
fools the discriminator uh in a nutshell
what's what scan
[Music]
and when we say non-auto-regressive it
means that
i mean the decoder part is
generates everything uh not
simultaneously in a way or
in another and this is a very basic uh
bunch of of about the uh the mel gun
architecture uh actually
we we need to also uh import melatons
tf and matplotlib to see uh
to display all the results and we will
use the tensorflow today's interference
part
uh to to do the inference using this
model and
the mel gun will be used as a decoder
for the second step
the first step as we talked about uh
talked about it before uh attack and
turn 2
we we will then uh importer import it
and i think khalil talked about it so i
will
skip this part to to have more part for
um
for the uh uh for the questions
a second uh model that we will use is
called fast speech
uh which is if if we try to understand
what's fast speech in a nuts naturally
anihua it's a neural network based on
end-to-end text-to-speech
these models are parameter
approaches norm based or neural network
based end-to-end models suffer from slow
interference
speed when you're going to do the
testing
and you want something which is real
time the
the there is a slow interference speed
and the synthetic speed
is usually not robust it means that some
some words are can be escaped to allah
repeated
a lack of control uh control ability
sorry
uh which is like voice speed uh can can
we um like
any speed or or have a speedy voice or
or
uh or not and the porosity control
this work uh this is the basic their
basic abstract actually
uh from uh from the fat speech
paper which is basically um
they propose a feed forward network
based on transformers so so basically
they have the use transformer for for
getting the attention
the most important part in the in your
uh
in your speech in your text or something
like that to generate male spectrograms
uh in parallel
meaning that you don't have to go uh
all the way to uh i mean to the uh
sorry uh to the whole uh you see the
whole uh
speech to be able to generate the result
which is the parallel and that's the non
autograph uh result and then
there is uh also which is basically uh
so basically they extract the attention
alignments from the
encoder decoder i think uh you have seen
the attention kind of line
alignment that you have that khalil have
talked about uh
in the presentation and this is part
from the encoder decoder based teacher
model so we have a teacher model
for phoneme durations prediction which
is used by a length regulator to expand
the source phoneme sequence to match the
length of the target mel
spectrogram sequence and all of this for
a parallelogram generation
so uh the the results is that it speed
up the male
spectrogram generation by uh 270 times
which is really important and
really um interesting for uh for getting
the uh
i mean uh trying everything out in a
more speedy way the first piece to do
is an improvement to fast speech which
is basically
uh so you have like a teacher
student it uses actually a technique
which is basically used really much
this much in uh nowadays which is called
self-supervised learning which is
basically you have a teacher student
distillation pipeline
and uh yeah so so basically
uh this is for for fast speech and one
of the
this is one of the disadvantages is
because the teacher student distillation
pipeline is complicated and time
consuming
and the duration extracted from the
teacher model is now accurate enough and
the target male spectrograms distillated
from the teacher model
suffer from information loss due to data
simplification or ella both of
which limit the voice quality el el faso
ii is actually um try to
solve two too many mapping problems
by by using actually training the model
with ground truth targets instead of
simplified
output from the teacher and then
introducing more variation
information like speech energy and more
accurate duration as
conditional inputs and
yeah this is just uh the the major the
experiments the results
it shows that it achieves three times
training speed over as fast speech
uh fast speech to also uh have better
faster interference speed
and it outperforms fast speech in voice
quality
and can either super surpass the auto
regressive models that only
have to do the the decoding part uh
one by one not in parallel
okay uh so so this is the malgal
original there is the there is different
mel guns
uh there is the melgan sdft
uh which is basically um fourier
transformer
kind of loss that they use to to improve
the results and then there is the
multiband
milgam i will not go into the technical
details because we're running out of
time
i'm sorry about this but if we try to
see the interference of the results
what we try to do is we try to generate
or to do the synthesis
basically using tecatron fast speech uh
fast ps2
this these are the only models that this
uh notebook
uses and we can see for example for the
the coder part the second part
that we talked about using the mel gun
for example the first one mel gan
or multi uh metis van melgan or the
melgen sft okay
after all of this
what we got to do is for example this is
the tech control true plus mel gan
and this is the kind of the results as
you can see the
uh the alignment the attention alignment
is quite good
but there are some some parts which are
very lacking
and if we try to hear i hope you can
hear me
we can hear you fine you you can hear me
you can hear it or not yes no no wait
the
can you click on on play actually okay
you can't right we can't you should have
a button at the top of your
[Music]
of your video to allow the the system
audio
okay you can i hope you can hear it
right now
so basically uh just to make sure this
is the
uh this is the text that we're trying to
generate
so it's basically bill get into the
habit of asking himself
if this is uh that uh thought true and
if he
wasn't absolutely certain it was he's
just let it go
and this is the input text and now you
can hear the results
bill got in the habit of asking himself
is that thought true
and if he wasn't absolutely certain it
was he just let it go
as you can hear right now it's just like
it's a good results but
as as you can see this in this part of
alignment there's kind of some robotic
kind of sound
and this is part and this is due to this
this kind of
uh not very uh great alignment
okay let's try to let's try takatron
true plus
the mel gun stft
asking himself is that thought true bill
got in the habit of asking himself is
that thought true
and if he wasn't absolutely certain tit
was
he just let it go okay
and we can see that using the mel gun
improved the results
okay and then there is the tekken tron 2
plus
multiband can
bill got in the habit of asking himself
is that thought true
and if he wasn't absolutely certain it
was
he just let it go okay i think
i will try to only use the fast peach
mel gun
bill got in the habit of asking himself
is that thought true
and if he wasn't absolutely certain it
was he just let it go
the the most important part is that the
even
the the speech understand the intonation
you will you will get it this
uh at the end some some uh
some models does not get the right
intonation in in when speaking but
some models like fastpitch 2 with
with mel gun will will get really good
bill got in the habit of asking himself
is that thought true
and if he wasn't absolutely certain it
was he just let it go
so sometimes it just stops and then
continues it's like
another sentence bill got in the habit
of asking himself is that thought true
and if he wasn't absolutely certain it
was he just let it go
okay and the last part is that the fast
speech too
i hope bill got in the habit of asking
himself is that thought true
and if he wasn't absolutely certain it
was
he just let it go you can hear like in
this one past speech two plus mel
uh multiband mel gun is that how how
perfect it gives the
intonation about each part when talking
in english
uh this sound seems really good compared
to to
the attack contour or fast speech and uh
it's not robotic so
sometimes it is it sounds a robotics for
for tacotron 2 or for a fast speech
you know it's it's really uh it gives
really good results
okay let's try it bill got in the habit
of asking himself is that
thought true and if he wasn't absolutely
certain it was
he just let it go
okay and the last one is the festive
bill got in the habit of asking himself
is that thought true and if he wasn't
absolutely certain it was
he just let it go and this is kind of
the difference between the
the different model i mean fast fish 2
gives
gives really great results compared to
tacotron 2 when when it comes to
not having uh i mean the uh
having not having that that robotic kind
of uh
results or not not sounding like very
very robotic
you so it sounds like very human and it
gets the intonation
as i said like very perfectly
some of the models stop in the middle
for example of the sentence because
it like for example and if it wasn't
absolutely certain it was and it stops
and then
it just let it go and some some of the
other models just
carries on uh to to say to say it
in a non-very uh non-very human way
yeah i'm not sure if you have any kind
of questions
but i think this is just what we wanted
to try to show you i know it's not in
arabic
we're sorry about that but unfortunately
we cannot
share for now the the arabic part that
we
have worked on and yeah i think i will
stop sharing my screen
cool thank you very much so uh we have a
question
uh so what's the hardware used for
milgans
uh typically a one t4
uh gpu can can be uh
can be enough yeah uh
if you want to add something on it yes
yes that's it yes
a t4 one gpu t4 can you can work on it
but
it takes it takes a you i think it needs
like
one t4 with 16 i think gigabytes so
something like that okay nice so amir is
asking
it's not clear which approach fast
speech 2 or
tacotron 2 is better can you please
comment what is the current tts state of
the art
so so basically if you try to see the um
the the models that we have shared the
results
all of them gives good really good
results as we have shared in the
notebook
but the fast piece to can can gives very
uh it's it's a lot more uh easier to uh
because it has
the parallel kind of uh kind of the
results and i think past speech two is
the state of the art
related to to the training uh right
khalid
[Music]
yeah is this right right now
uh the state of the art uh for
uh for generating good quality audios
and you can hear it as we
we showcased it in the in the notebook
so so basically
uh tacotron sometimes can can be very uh
very hard to uh
yeah sometimes i have some robot example
that's which to give more
clear and natural sound
compared yeah okay
thank you uh so can you share the
notebook link with the
the attendees yes sure uh thank you very
much
thank you thank you amen and thank you
khalil for this session
uh it was clear and very good thank you
so finally we are we come to an end with
our last
uh talk with uh karim gear
from steady the ceo and co-founder of
estadip
as a graduate of france ecole
polytechnique
and former program fellow at new york
university's current institute
kalim has a passion for teaching and
using applied mathematics
he is also a google developer expert and
a mentor at google for startups
accelerator and is a steering community
member of
deep learning in dubba welcome kelly
thank you for having me it's a pleasure
to be here
our pleasure is yours uh so you will be
talking about ai language models
latest developments the stage is yours
absolutely and uh please tell me if you
see uh my screen in
present mode yeah it's working fine
perfect well uh first uh it's pleasure
to be here
and we're very excited uh that uh you
know this tensorflow meetup tunis is
happening
and hopefully there will be many more of
those we're also excited that it's a
you know a diverse team of talents uh
from instead
from icombas and other volunteers as
well so
this is this is really great and this is
really we believe the future
for the ecosystem in indonesia when it
comes to
ai and today you've had different
sessions about
language modeling and very interesting
uh you know discussions about
practicals i wanted to share with you
sort of my
perspective about what's happening in
language models
why you should be paying attention uh
beyond the examples discussed today
so it's probably a less sort of
programming but more like mathematical
and sort of uh
you know overview but uh still thought
it was important
uh to get you a sense so first i mean
when we're talking language models we
here we're really talking about
attention-based models and transformers
and
as uh probably all of you should know by
now
uh you know transformers is a sort of a
revolution
uh because we are not processing uh
sequences uh
for example nlp just sequentially like
you we used to do it for
lstms or more generally like recurrent
neural networks
if you see here on my screen for example
like dependency
between you know the hidden layer t
uh for a large t and an x zero like the
initial uh
input token here is is is quite long and
grows
longer with the sequence length and what
transformers have changed is the fact
that now you're actually
looking at something where you have the
same
amount of interaction i would say
between the different
tokens no matter where they are in the
sentence for example if you take this
english sentence the animal didn't cross
the street because it was too tired
and really like if you look at the
dependency of
it you see that there's a strong link
with
the animal here which is highlighted in
a darker color
and that is super interesting because
you're directly modeling sort of the
interaction
and putting the weights where they are
from a purely data driven
way so transformers were created in 2017
but it's really over the last i'd say
two years that we've seen like
incredible incredible uh you know
innovation and speed and scaling along
these
and so what's the idea here uh this is
sort of like if you have to remember
something from this
presentation that would be probably it
the idea is like you probably heard
that software is eating the world right
and it's probably one of the reasons why
you're in this session today and this
was from mark anderson from
anderson horowitz in silicon valley then
we had deep learning is eating software
which was popularized by
andrei carpati notably the director of
ai at tesla
and what i would like to tell you and
it's sort of my own take on it
is that you know after deep learning
eating software
now you have transformers eating deep
learning itself so if you have
the world here uh its software is eating
it deep learning is eating software but
then transformer is eating deep learning
so that's kind of important when you
think about it that you should be
very familiar with what's going on on
transformers and i hope you enjoyed the
previous sessions
where you had several examples of you
know work
done especially for modeling arabic
language but also speech like we just
saw
with with ml and and so this
is really a very powerful technology and
what's super interesting from my
perspective
is transformers emerge in the context of
nlp and this is why we call it language
modeling
but the amazing thing that we've seen
over the last
six nine months is that now it is
starting to eat
other deep learning models and this is
why we say transformers are eating deep
learning
so if you look for example at
convolutional neural networks which were
sort of like the mainstay of ai vision
for a very long time
jan le cam from facebook ai invented
cnns in the late
80s and you know they've been like
powering
the whole ai vision revolution until
very recently where you had this
transformational paper and images worth
16 by 16 words by google ai
which effectively uh mentioned and
explained that
you could actually train transformers on
images on pixels
seeing basically cutting uh you know
pixels uh
effectively uh you know either 16x16 or
another and another type of dimension
but the idea is you cut your whole pixel
image
uh you're in in batches and then you
build relationship between those
and that is revolutionary for multiple
reasons first because
the vit model like the vision
transformer model by uh
by the authors actually got very good
results
so it's a technology that works so only
for that you should pay attention
but what's more interesting is that now
with this technology you can actually
link multiple modalities so in the
example below with this
with this picture of a surfer you could
build a
basically relationship between text that
describe describes the image
and the image itself pretty much
directly
with attention exactly like if if we
come back here
we had it depending on and related and
pointing to the animal
well you have the same idea here like
the person where is the person while you
see you have higher dependency here
riding etc so you could surfboard here
you
see it's lighting up these these patches
here
so the idea is that you're directly
modeling
pairwise uh interactions and this could
go beyond
simple pixels or simple text it could be
text
and vision or it could be text and
vision and speech
like you just saw with with ml that
speech also
works pretty well so that's the idea
here is
this is powerful and in this particular
case transformers
and attention-based models are now
becoming very competitive
in vision tasks and when you think about
it this was not something obvious
because
cnns have been used on the notion of
translation in variances and other
invariances which are
based on like visual tasks and visual
priors that
the human designers put into them
transformers don't have that
in a sense it's a more general priority
the notion of
okay i'm gonna have different uh parts
or different tokens
interact and sort of measure their
interaction directly
by by data and yet it is competitive on
vision so
in in general like when a speech when i
say
an ai technology like ai becomes
very powerful and very big you tend to
see specialization
you tend to see for example like you
know
speech going with lstms vision going
with cnns
and it's very rare that the technology
comes and
unifies the the field again the field
which got in much bigger and much more
like subset specialized and this is
exactly what happened with transformers
so that is super interesting and indeed
you can also see that transformers and
language models are also eating biology
because if you look at biology and
proteins which are
basically the macromolecular engines
that are powering uh
life you know they're based on sequences
amino acid sequences and 20 of them
and those sequences directly
create shapes whether alpha helix or
beta sheets
that create ultimately a 3d structure
that is going to drive the function of
proteins in your body whether it's for
energy like energy generation
for movement with muscles and others and
the idea here is the same way we created
dependencies between tokens in a
sequence
like we saw before you could actually
create dependencies on the different
amino acids
effectively proteins is a language made
by 20 amino acids so there's only like
20 different tokens
but the relationships they create are
quite complex you see here
in interactions between the these
different amino acids creating
hydrogen bonds and other interactions
here and so
if you take this and do it at a very
large scale
if you build attention models at a very
large scale what you get
ultimately is the biggest
scientific breakthrough of the last year
which is what deepmind did with alpha
fall 2
basically a system that goes from
sequence alone
through the use of transformers and
attention at a very large scale
purely data driven in in many ways and
and get you
exactly to understand and predict the
shape of proteins
so you don't need to understand the
detail of what's going on here except
that
you know the color the color is actually
the prediction
here in in this one and here the other
color is the experimental result and you
see that
they fit almost perfectly and in a
scoring
this is the gasp competition you see
alpha fall 2 here
literally smashed everything so why am i
showing you this and
why is this important it's important
because it shows you that
a general purpose technology such as
transformers and language model
can actually go and beat ultra
specialized
uh you know teams and technologies in
this particular case
in in in biology and biophysics
by a very large margin so in a sense
if you master technology such as
language models attention-based models
well you have a tool which is
extraordinarily powerful and i hope you
understand
why now we're saying that transformers
are eating
deep learning and and deep learning
itself is is the new software
so i wanted to sort of attract your
attention now on
why in particular this is happening this
is happening because
language models scale very very well
there is a paper
from uh open ai which is one of my
favorites so uh
for the people who are at instead they
probably saw this because
it's one of my favorite papers not a
super recent paper but a very important
one from open ai
where they literally went and studied
the scaling properties of
transformers and so i'm just giving you
like the key ideas here
the idea is that first when you have a
model
and you're looking at a particular
problem and you're trying to reduce test
loss
ultimately test loss is a function of
compute data and parameter size
you you tell me okay well did i did i
really
need to know this again it's kind of
obvious well i'll tell you something
that's not obvious
it's the fact that it's actually a power
law it's pretty amazing here like the
fit you get and this is like
experimental fitting to uh to like doing
all the experiments and
fitting like empirically what you see
you
have like almost perfect power laws that
is
interesting so in a sense you can
predict
what is going to happen if you put in
more compute
add more data or add more parameters and
to this point
you can actually get the test loss to be
a direct function
empirically of parameter size and and
data
i mean if you think about it like for
most of us in machine learning
it's the notion of okay i'm gonna reduce
the loss
it's pretty much like okay will i get to
a good result or not but the notion that
the loss itself would actually be a
quantifiable function
of inputs such as model parameters and
and data set size that is super
interesting
and you can directly extract from this
very sort of usable insights for example
if you increase your parameter size by
8x
you know you know that at some point you
know the data
the data you you might overfit the data
but
where are the critical thresholds and
you see here that
i ideally if you increase eight
experiment the size you should be
increasing data 5x and so you are
capable actually to
understand what's happening in your
model and
derive some things which might be not
very
intuitive such as insights such as
for example if you like if you have a
larger model
you're actually going to get to good
results faster
than if you have a smaller model you
might think i mean at least me or
sometimes i thought that
if i have a larger model i need to feed
it a lot of data and okay it's going to
get me to a good results but i might
need to feed it a lot of data to get to
a very good result
well that's not true actually and if you
see here
by the number of tokens processed if you
have a given number of tokens
if i block myself here at a billion
tokens for example
well you're going to see that basically
the larger model
has a much better loss
for the same amount of tokens processed
than the smaller model
this is true actually at any number of
tokens processed
so you might say okay but that's that's
just due to
you know compute you have more compute
because to run a model like this you
need a lot more compute
well that's actually not true
like if you have a given compute budget
it's better to have a larger model
yes it's gonna run on less epochs it
might not converge
but it's still gonna get you better
results and by better results i mean
better test loss for a given test loss
objective or let's say a given compute
budget
so imagine this you have a compute
budget you're wondering like
should i train a smaller model for a
long a very long time or should i trade
a bigger model and even though i don't
reach convergence
like meaning that the test loss doesn't
plateau or goes back
back up well it's actually better to
have a larger model so
and again you can quantify those
relationships so my point here
is that machine learning with
transformers
unifies the field but it's also making
it
more scientific if i may say and
scientific more in the sense of
physics not mathematics because these
are empirical laws
but yet they are quite important then
they will explain to you for example
i mean some of the work we do can be
quite
compute intensive for example the
collaboration we did
between insta-deep and icompass to
create convert which we just open
sourced for the community
well that required a significant amount
of effort
and decent amount of compute as well not
massive compute like
you know like the tech giants like
google or facebook but still a very
significant amount of compute
so you have to be more scientific about
the way you design your experiments
and importantly understand that if
you're going to dedicate
more compute how should you relatively
speaking
grow your model size your batch size
the number of epochs for example
that you're going to be doing on a
particular training and it turns out
that for
nlp and transformers you have pretty
stable relationships
and the interesting one is that you
better grow the model size
rather in relative terms much more than
the batch size
and much more than increasing the number
of epochs
these are kind of insights which are not
obvious
when we tell you this after the facts it
might seem obvious but it really wasn't
and this is important because it allows
you to sort of plan ahead and say okay
if i'm gonna dedicate
i don't know like uh like you know in a
large experiment
one petaflop day of compute budget
well where this this likely to get me a
test loss and how should i
allocate optimally a model size by size
and serial uh
and and amounts of fbx and when you
think about it this is exactly
what openai did i'm sure all of you are
familiar with
gpt3 which came in from open ai uh
pretty much a year ago
and which was gigantic or say gigantic
for
at the time with 175 billion uh training
data which was
just massive with a 400 billion world
tokens
taken from internet and all the
encyclopedia of the world and
etc and you see that gpt3 starts to
become so good that it will confuse
and hear this is basically humans
accuracy at detecting gpt3 versus real
news
articles and you see that it's sort of
converging to 50 percent
uh when the model the transformer model
gets
bigger and bigger uh 50 means that you
know you're not better than
a monkey at uh guessing whether this is
ai or this is
actually real news article and this is
actually an example that
i find pretty fascinating totally
generated by gpt3
about some still vague story about unit
united method it's agreeing to a
historic
split i would challenge you that if you
show this to someone who does no context
that to guess that this is ai and we
sort of played this game uh
like uh you know with with a few people
at
instagram we were showing like some text
and some speech in in chat on on slack
and
and people could not guess is it like
somebody real speaking or is it
is it like gpt3 so again this shows you
the power of scaling transformers
and maybe like we don't have too much
time but i just want to say a few words
about the fact that research is
continuing to advance extremely quick
and now you have new technologies that
are coming in
new insights and particularly from
google which is
you know one of the very best if not the
best team in the world when it comes to
ai
research and switch transformer which
came in uh early this year
is pretty remarkable because until now
what i've shown you is effectively
if i'm gonna scale the number of
parameters i'm gonna scale
compute uh budget pretty much
accordingly
but that doesn't need to be true like
you could actually scale
the number of parameters get to a
trillion parameter
and still be quite compute efficient
so how does this work and how does this
accelerate transformers
well is the notion that you know when
you're looking here at
your self-attention layer you have a
feed-forward layer which is usually here
and what you're doing in this particular
case is rather than having a classic
uh feet forward and where you're taking
basically your whole
hidden dimension and pushing it further
well you're going to have
different feed forwards or different
experts and you have a routing system
that's going to say okay
in this particular case based on those
embeddings
i'm going to route and use feed forward
no like network number two and etc so
you could get like hundreds of experts
this way
and a much bigger uh set a much bigger
model
uh in this uh in the paper actually
google goes up to 1.6 trillion
and uh to my knowledge you know like the
best ai models at the moment are around
these
the chinese have done something uh
similar on chinese language as well
but what is interesting here is that
when you are actually
do going to at inference time you're
going to go only through
one of those layers here so that means
that
you are not less efficient or bigger
from a compute budget than
a classic transformer so for the same
flops budget
you can actually infer at the same speed
the the only difference is now that your
model is much bigger and has a lot more
parameter diversity and indeed it gets
better efficiency when you are doing
training and training speed ups
this is super interesting because now we
are in the world of
trillion parameter models but efficient
models
and so this at the as a smaller scale
can apply to
the work all of us do meaning that you
know those
are models that can be richer in terms
of acquiring pattern
but not more expensive to deploy at this
time so i think in particular this this
model is super exciting
and when you think about multi-modality
with it
and also all the progress which is
happening in self-supervised
you see that there is really a framework
where transformer models
uh you know ranking in even you know
much more than
trillion parameter models i i would
imagine that this is going to grow
continue to grow very quickly i'm going
to get to a point where they absorb
data at the scale and efficiency where
the results are going to be nothing
short of
remarkable so i'll stop here and
just to conclude and take some questions
if you were to remember something from
this presentation
well remember that transformers are
eating deep learning or language models
are eating deep learning
so it's a very good time to learn more
and get familiar
with those models in a sense probably
the best investment you might make
if it was like four or five years ago
you would have needed to learn about
lstms rnns and cnns well here you don't
have to you just learn
transformers and you have something
that's going to work and attention-based
models are going to work for pretty much
everything you can do
those models scale very well and we
haven't reached their limits yet but
importantly
those sort of behavior can be quantified
in a remarkable degree of
empirical accuracy i would say and now
with
more efficient use of compute for the
number of parameters that of your model
with multi-modality and you know of
course the revolution self-supervised
learning
which we will keep for another day and
that's a whole subject on itself
you're getting at the point where you
know someone
who is passionate about learning and
deploying this type of technologies
can really reach new breakthroughs i
hope you know the work
that the insta deep and icompass teams
did on tunebird
inspired you to dig further use the open
sourcing technology that we had
also use the open source tools that you
have on tensorflow hub the link is here
but this is a fast-moving world where
you can really make a difference
and it's never been a more exciting time
to be
learning about ai using ai and
innovating with ai so thanks a lot for
uh for listening to presentation and i'm
happy
uh to take questions from here
uh thank you kevin so we have a question
uh attention mechanisms seems seem to be
central to the success of
transformers nlp cv time series etc
is there any init and initiate
an intuitive explanation for this for
example hidden layers are what enabled
universal approximations in neural
networks do you think something similar
is happening with attention mechanisms
i i think i'll i'll i'll give you my
intuition about what's happening with
the retention
attention is a sort of a universal
computational engine uh like uh
primitive
that's how i would say so what do i mean
by this is that
the world is driven by computation and
attention is just an efficient way to
model that computation
and provide rich enough computation to
capture
the behavior that you that you're
looking for there is a super interesting
uh
paper actually that came recently uh
by peter abhill and some colleagues in
in
in i think university of berkeley that
says
transformers are universal computational
engines what does it mean
it means that if i take something like
gpt3 okay
it's been trained on english for nlp
and that's it imagine i freeze gpt3
and i want to train for arabic
or anything else or for proteins in
biology
i just changed my input so i'm gonna
need an encoder layer obviously because
you're gonna feed you know basically uh
embedding so you just need to change the
embedding layer
and let's assume i just changed the
final feed forward layer of my network
to get to the and
reshape to the output i want for my
problem i
freeze gpg3 in between
what what do you think is going to
happen what is the amazing thing is that
actually it works very very well
and you don't have to retrain a lot so
effectively
attention mechanisms are sort of
universal and
they could be trained for something that
has nothing to do with the problem
you're looking at
and frozen so all the attention layers
are frozen you're just changing
the final layer and the first layer like
the embedding and the feed forward at
the end
and that would still get you to amazing
results that sometimes could beat
models that been designed for this
problem so to answer your question and
that's a great question
it's coming from the fact that the
attention mechanism captures a sort of
computational primitive and
computational richness for
lack of a better word that works very
very well and that's also means that you
as a practitioner you could start
actually
with a pre-trained model just do what
they just uh
told you and you might actually get very
good results without having to
spend the you know a few better flops of
compute budgets so it's an exciting time
thank you graeme that was the only
question we have
so thank everyone and every participant
and every speaker today and for all the
participants you can find in the chat
the links for the
github repos and thank you all see you
to in next in our next event thanks a
lot
see you guys soon thank you
you